hello everyone welcome to the november
2020 ask me anything edition of the
mindscape podcast
i'm your host john carroll let me
explain what's going on here
as some of you know we have a patreon
for people who want to support mindscape
financially
you can go to patreon.com sean m
carroll and there's two benefits for
actually contributing to the patreon one
is you get ad-free versions
of the podcast and the other is every
month we do one of these
ama episodes ask me anything episodes so
near the end of the month
i put up a post on patreon and anyone
who's a patreon supporter can ask a
question
and i try don't always succeed but i try
my best to
answer every question that is asked and
this episode represents that
so these episodes these ama recordings
are published on patreon near the end of
the month
in fact this one that you're about to
listen to if you're going to listen to
it
came out at the beginning of november
just before the presidential election
which seems like years ago
now but what happened is a lot of the
patreon supporters
by their own initiative said it'd be
better if we could share
the results of the ama widely not just
to
patreon supporters so patreon supporters
will continue to get
the benefit of being able to ask
questions on the ama
but going forward anyone will be able to
listen to the answers so we're going to
make it just a regular part of the
mindscape feed uh it won't replace the
regular episode so it won't get a number
uh we're gonna release these episodes in
the middle of the month so the patreon
supporters get
a week or two after the ama came out to
listen to it and know in their hearts
that only they have been able to hear it
and then we're going to send it out to
everybody so as i always say here
no pressure to join on patreon or
anything like that
where the happy community whether or not
money is exchanging hands
but i would like to convey my thanks to
the patreon community for suggesting
that we share
these ama episodes more widely so these
words i'm saying right now are replacing
the intro i did for the actual ama that
the patreon supporters heard
because i was only talking about the
election that was going to come up in a
day or two
not really relevant anymore going
forward this is going to be
uh the same intro that you get for the
wide thing
and for the patreon supporters usually i
babble on for a couple minutes about
something that has been going on in the
last week and then we dive into the
questions
so let's do that let's go
manuel bavonda says what is an opinion
you used to have that you completely
changed your mind about
um i mean i i hesitate on this one just
because there are so many
and i guess it depends a little bit on
what you mean by opinion
if we stick just to science i definitely
had the opinion
that the cosmological constant was
probably zero
and then we discovered it in 1998 uh
which made the universe a lot more
interesting place
so that's a very clear-cut case where
everyone changed their mind i think
um you know on more uh wishy-washy
things where your mind is not changed by
uh vivid startling data that comes in
you know i used to be someone who
philosophically thought
that uh was more i guess what you would
call uh scientistic
about morals and ethics and things like
that
um someone who thought that you know
we're uh human beings we're living
organisms we
we developed where we are by a
biological evolution and you could use
those features of who we are as human
beings to derive
clear philosophical guidelines for what
is right and what is wrong
um i see the fallacies in that now right
so
i changed my mind about there you go
there's one there's many many other
opinions but
that's one of them elias boreansen
uh borison sorry no n sorry elias
do you use lot tech or microsoft word
for your publications
um this is an excellent question uh for
those of you who
are not working scientists or in that
field scientists or anyone who uses
equations a lot in their writing tends
to use this uh typesetting program
called
latex it looks like it's spelled latex
but it's pronounced latex trust me on
that and uh
so certainly for research publications
i'm going to use latex there's lots of
equations in them
there's really just not even a choice i
know microsoft word has
some equation capability but it's it's
not
in the same league as law tech is now
for articles or something like that that
you would
uh put like if i send something to new
york times for example
it has to be microsoft word those are
the that's the only format that they
will accept so i
was dragged kicking and screaming into
using microsoft word
um for long form publications
well for a textbook you still got to use
lottech because there's a lot of
equations in it but
for other books for popular books i use
something called scrivener
the publishers will only accept
microsoft word
but if you have a book that's 100 000
words long
either you have one giant document
which is very big and it's hard to find
things in it and you don't know what
you're doing
uh or you have in microsoft word you
know one document per chapter that's how
i wrote from eternity to here
um but there are but scrivener is an
example of a program that is meant for
long-term long-form writing so it has
one big file but separate files within
the big file within the document as they
call it or the project or whatever it's
called
within the project there's different
files for
chapters and also you can import
research like you can import pdf files
or figures or whatever
into the one project and it sort of
looks like a book and so if you suddenly
say
well actually i want to move chapter
eight and make it chapter six
trivial to do something like that in
scrivener and you can search the whole
document all at once
so it's it's a very good thing a lot of
book writers use that
aaron disario says in april 2020 the u.s
department of defense released a
statement about three unclassified navy
videos that have been circulating on the
internet for a few years
then aaron goes on to add more details
about
ufo sightings and other things like that
and he says can you be convinced that we
are visiting
being visited right now so to me this
has a very similar feeling to
is there anything that convince you that
could convince you that god exists
because the answer is of course there is
if god
existed it would be no problem for him
to convince me that he existed
right he just has to come visit tell me
he exists you know manifest in such a
way that it would be
almost impossible to fake it and the
more he did things that only god could
do the more i would believe that it was
god i'm a good bayesian
more evidence i collect the more likely
it is but
in fact the world we live in
looks exactly like you would expect it
to look if god doesn't exist
right you can argue that god should
exist but you never see
god in the everyday world and this is a
long
argument obviously not everyone agrees
with me but that's how i see it
and the same thing is true with aliens
visiting us in ufos
as a good bayesian what you're trying to
do here is to compare
two different comprehensive views of the
world one in which
aliens uh intelligent extraterrestrials
highly technologically advanced come to
visit us um
and they hide right like they don't make
it easy they don't come and announce
themselves they sort of
have enough advanced technology that
they can fly
light years uh across the galaxy and
come visit us and they kind of hide
but not very effectively right so you
can see some flashing lights and people
in their backyards
see things and navy pilots make
recordings of things that seem to be
moving very fast
because the aliens have the technology
to fly
many light years across the galaxy but
number one for some reason they want to
stay hidden
number two they're not very good at it
uh and number three
the you know there's there's the we
should trust or we should we should have
credence in
uh the views of all these people who
claim that the only way
they can explain what they've seen is
ufos that's one theory
that's one possible hypothesis the other
is
people make mistakes people are wrong
people see things they misinterpret them
they make videos of them there are all
sorts of errors in the videos whether
from
lens flares or you know optical
illusions or whatever and there are no
aliens visiting us
in my mind given what we currently know
including all the
unclassified videos blah blah blah it is
overwhelmingly more likely
that aliens have not been visiting us
because if aliens had not been visiting
us i would still expect
some people to claim that they were i
mean that's what people do people
claim all sorts of crazy things i would
still expect
that people would take sort of very
vague sort of
interpretable in various ways pieces of
evidence
and spin them i would also expect that
people just lie and fabricate right
because it's kind of cool and people
some people can even run industries you
know get paid off of
this kind of belief whereas if the
aliens
really existed and were visiting us i i
don't think they would hide at all they
would just say hi
with overwhelming probability so given
the current evidence
i have very very close to zero credence
that aliens are visiting us
but if you want to say is there anything
that could convince me
sure the aliens just got to come down
and introduce themselves
it's not that hard like the amount of
mental gymnastics you have to go through
to imagine the aliens are visiting us
but we don't really know it very well
seems to me to be a little bit
implausible okay peter gerdes
says when you argue for the born rule in
terms of what would be rational to
expect
what's the connection between what's
rational to expect and what we've
actually observed in other words
do you take your analysis to explain why
it's unsurprising we seem to actually
seem to have evidence that validates the
born rule or does it only give us reason
to place forward-looking bets in
accordance with the porn rule
i don't know if there's some subtext
here but uh the answer is no it goes
both ways
i think that the all the reasoning that
says you should uh
place credences on what branch of the
wave function you're on according to the
born rule
works both forward and backward in time
i'm not sure why it uh
why it shouldn't so and that i mean we
have a whole paper i mean the
whole section in the paper that i wrote
with ships evens on deriving the bourne
rule
on um theory confirmation you know okay
how is it that you can sort of
simultaneously confirm
the specific ui ideas you have about the
wave function of a certain system
and the broader framework in which
you're working in which the board rule
gives the right statistics but
but it's pretty straightforward it's
just bayesian reasoning it works it
works both directions of time no problem
dave stern says i remember you saying
that it is easier to do some
calculations assuming many worlds than
using more traditional methods of
calculation
is my memory correct um i guess that
depends what you mean by the word
calculations i don't i don't think it's
necessarily easier to do
calculations assuming many worlds but it
depends on exactly what you're trying to
calculate
what i there's two things that i
definitely have said
one is that it is easier to conceptually
understand some purported paradoxes of
quantum mechanics
from a many worlds perspective or some
puzzles or some
some weird features of quantum mechanics
for example
best example would be the delayed choice
quantum eraser which doesn't seem at all
mysterious to someone who believes in
many worlds
and slightly relatedly but slightly
differently i've also said that
there are legitimate puzzles in
theoretical physics like quantum gravity
for example
which you might have a new and
productive angle on
if you believe in many worlds versus
other theories of quantum gravity
so it's less about doing calculations
than about understanding i would say
matt barber says i just went through the
something deeply hidden audiobook
i have a question about the alice and
bob entanglement thought experiment
where bob flies to alpha centauri
alice measures spin up and then bob
measures spin up because of entanglement
action distance etc
what i'm used to hearing from popular
explanation of relativity is that the
notion of before and after depends on
the frame of reference so is there a
fact of the matter whether alice
actually measures spin up
before bob um no there's not you're
exactly right that's what relativity
says
uh relativity says that what happens
before
and what happens after for two events
that are separated by a large distance
in space
will be different can be different if
they're if they're
spaced like separated is the technical
term that we say
can be different can depend on the frame
of reference or more generally the
coordinate system
that someone uses in space-time so the
rules of quantum mechanics have to be
that if you have spins entangled two
spins entangled in the sense that
they're both spin up or both spin down
let's say
then it doesn't matter who measures
first there's just one fact one
prediction of quantum mechanics that
they're both going to measure the same
spin and that's true whether bob
measures first or whether alice does
jacob schneider says is creating
emergent theories too easy
i feel like hilberspace is so large that
it becomes almost infinitely flexible
like maybe it's possible to create any
emerging classical theory you want as
long as you make the right definitions
in course grading or at least to
approximate any theory that you want
uh no i think it's exactly the opposite
to be honest i think that
it's a miraculous that immersion
theories
exist at all it's not at all easy to
make them because remember
what you need for a theory to be
properly emergent
is an ability to make somewhat reliable
predictions using that theory
on the basis of a very very very tiny
amount of the initial
data for the actual system so when you
have you know the air in the room
and you say well really we know it's a
bunch of atoms and molecules and every
atom and molecule has a position and a
velocity
but what we're going to do is give you
just the fluid dynamical
degrees of freedom so you know maybe in
every cubic millimeter
of the room i'll tell you the
temperature and velocity and pressure
and things like that
so that temperature velocity pressure
data is way way
way less data than giving you all the
positions and velocities of all the
atoms
but it suffices to make really really
accurate predictions for what the air in
the room is going to do
that is a highly non-generic situation
the example i've used very often before
is what you did in that sort of
emergence
is you you averaged over what was going
on in every cubic centimeter of space
you could also take averages for example
in momentum space
right invent a quantity which is the
average
position uh for all the molecules with a
certain momentum
rather than the average momentum for all
molecules with a certain position
so you get a whole bunch of data and
from it you can do nothing
you can't make any predictions at all
and that's the much more generic
situation if you don't have some
structure in your theory that allows
emergence to happen
you generally need to know almost all
the initial data to make
precise predictions about what's going
to happen next so i would not say that
creating immersion theories is easy at
all
joshua hillerup says you've said before
that many worlds is just the wave
function of the universe evolving as per
the schrodinger equation
do you actually mean the
non-relativistic schrodinger equation
here or are using that to mean whatever
method best describes quantum physics
uh so i encourage you to read my book
joshua something deeply hidden
the schrodinger equation is not the same
as the non-relativistic schrodinger
equation
which kind of should be obvious since
otherwise you wouldn't need
something called the non-relativistic
schrodinger equation the existence of
something called the non-relativistic
schrodinger equation
implies the existence of a more general
schrodinger equation
so when i say the schrodinger equation i
mean the most general
form of it which physicists would write
as h
psi equals i d by dt psi where psi is
the wave function
h is what's called the hamiltonian
operator and d by dt is the time
derivative
and i is the square root of minus one so
that equation
that general form of the schrodinger
equation is completely true in
any version of quantum mechanics it
doesn't matter whether it's relativistic
non-relativistic
whether it's the standard model or qed
or loop quantum gravity or super string
theory or whatever
this is the fundamental equation of all
forms of quantum mechanics
robert ruxin rescue says i'm wondering
what's your take on the ontology of the
universe my own opinion
is that as you get deeper on the scale
of reductionism what you end up with is
the abstract laws of nature that are
immutable and exist without the need of
a creator
since you can't really grasp them and
destroy them they don't have a choice
but to exist
therefore i feel like the ontology of
the universe might be math itself like
max tegmark is proposing well i think
uh this is going to sound like a cop-out
maybe but i think that the universe
i'm what i call a reality realist the
universe is what exists
and there's this natural
tendency that people have to say okay
but what is
the universe and the response to that
would be you know what could
possibly qualify as an answer to that
question there's
the universe is not an example of a set
that we're otherwise familiar with
outside our experience of the universe
right it's like
is fred a mathematician or a physicist
well we know what mathematicians are and
physicists are we've met more than one
of them before and we can ask what fred
does but
the universe is not like that it's kind
of unique by by
construction so i think that you can
describe
the universe mathematically and i think
as we'll get to in a later question
i think the best current description we
have of it as is as a vector in hilbert
space that is the
representation of the universe but for
as for what the universe
is it's the universe that's there's
really nothing else
uh that is that is a completely adequate
way to describe it
nicholas walker says do you think the
dark matter and or energy will be
discovered at the quantum level
um i'm not sure what that means
discovered at the quantum level
you know i think that dark energy is
overwhelmingly likely to be the
cosmological constant i think we know
what it is to
a pretty good approximation with 90
confidence let's say
uh dark matter is probably some kind of
particle
um so i'm not sure what you mean uh at
the quantum level
the the the only level is the quantum
level in some sense all of the laws of
nature are fundamentally quantum
mechanical but i don't think that
so usually let's back up a little bit
usually when we say the quantum level
we are contrasting it with a classical
description the quantum description is
more comprehensive we never have to use
the classical description but there
might be
a set of approximate a set of conditions
under which a classical description is a
good approximation
so everything is at the quantum level
but in everyday language
we use the words quantum level to mean
outside of the domain of applicability
of the classical description
i don't see any reason why dark matter
or dark energy need to be outside
the domain of applicability of the
classical description
tyler whitmer says if you weren't
allowed to have cats would you choose
another animal as a pet and if so what
um i grew up with all sorts of pets you
know with dogs and with birds and
and fish and a whole bunch of things i
think that dogs and cats are the only
animals that i really enjoy having as
pets you know they're they're
a little bit smarter they have more
personality you know you can play with
them in a different way
but dogs are too much responsibility
honestly like you have to take them for
walks all the time
uh cats have a litter box as fans of
pretty litter a former advertiser on the
podcast will know
so and i like the cat's personality wise
also so i think
i think although it's it's hard to say
but i think my choices would be i would
have cats or i would just go
pet free entirely jose ignacio alcantara
says
do you think the truth and beauty are
related with regards to mathematical
descriptions of the physical world if it
came to a crunch
which would you choose um i mean
obviously you got to choose truth
over beauty like i would much rather
believe an ugly truth than
a beautiful falsehood
but they seem to be related i mean in
our
historical experience as we discover
uh more and more about the world the
descriptions that we cook up for those
things we discover
most often work out to be beautiful when
viewed from a certain light and i think
that that's you know
uh a very reasonable thing to say a very
truthful thing to say
about our search for truth so far
so the way that i think about it is
imagining that
future as yet un uh
tested physical theories will also be
beautiful
is a good starting point it has worked
in the past so
by all means use it to make guesses
about the future
but of course you choose the ones that
fit the data better
beauty is a guide to searching for
physical theories but it's not a guide
to choosing
between theories some of which fit the
data and some of which don't
victor alejandro weiner or wayner says
i keep hearing about research on room
temperature superconductivity this has
to date
uh been unsuccessful the whole
enterprise seems to be as impossible as
perpetual motion or alchemy
doesn't the notion of acquiring room
temperature superconductivity violate
the second law of thermodynamics
or is it a linguistic issue and in
reality they are looking for
near room temperature or near
superconductivity
um so i'm not sure what is what is
bothering you here victor you know
i could imagine a principled belief
that super conductivity could only
happen at zero temperature
but we've known for a long time that
that's not true there are temperatures
above zero
uh where things are superconducting and
it's not nearly super conducting in fact
this is one of the features
of superconductivity um
that basically it's on or off right it's
not like you creep up on it there's a
phase transition and you are now
superconducting versus you're not
and if that seems weird to you right
like why don't you creep up on super
conductivity you know
a metaphor that may or may not be useful
analogies you know they're always
they're always a little bit dangerous to
use
but imagine you know you're um packing
little cubes
into a box which fits exactly a certain
number of cubes
right and so there's going to be one way
to pack them forget about the
interchanging individual cubes but you
better line them up you know
facing the flat side of each other
because you don't have any other room
to fit the cubes in right so if you have
one cube that is at an angle or
something like that
then you're not going to fit all the
cubes in so the question of do you fit
all the cubes in the box or not is a yes
or no
question and superconductivity is kind
of like that there's a phase transition
into a state where there's zero
resistance as things move down
and if you are willing to believe that
that's possible
at 10 degrees kelvin then it's just an
engineering problem to say well can we
do it at
200 or 300 kelvin right i mean there's
no
phase transition there there's no big uh
difference between those two things it's
really kind of a matter of degree
and of course i'm not quite sure how
much you've been following the news but
they have
achieved room temperature super
conductivity it is unfortunately not at
room
pressure you have to put incredible
pressure like squeeze diamonds together
on this material to make it superconduct
at room temperature but
they can do it it's not going to change
the world technologically
anytime soon but it could happen down
the line homberto nani says
are laplace's conservation of
information and quantum mechanics's
unitarity
meant to traverse the big bang event uh
we don't know
we don't know what happened at the big
bang we don't know if there was anything
traversing anything at the big bang
event the big bang could be the
beginning
of time it could be a moment through
which yes there is unitary evolution and
conservation of information or it could
just be like a fuzzy approximation
sitting as a placeholder for our future
knowledge that that isn't there yet so
um i'm very willing to believe and
explore personally the idea
that quantum mechanics uh that there is
unitary evolution through the big bang
but it's certainly something that
we don't know yet and it's not even
clear what it would mean to say
it's meant to traverse that we just
don't know
andrew says what's your process for
preparing for interviews you're always
so up to speed not only in each guest's
work
but also the context of their work even
in disciplines outside your own
uh you know it depends on the interview
obviously like when i have adam reese
on the podcast talking about cosmology i
don't do any
preparation whatsoever roughly speaking
whereas if i have
a historian or an economist i'm going to
have to work
harder than that so you know part of the
inspiration for starting the podcast in
the first place was that i had a long
pile of books
a tall pile of books by my bed that i
wanted to read and kept buying and
couldn't find the time to read
so i kind of nudged myself into reading
some of these books
by having their authors appear as guests
on the podcasts
now i i'll be very very honest i do not
always read every word of every book
right you know i
sometimes you got to skim sometimes time
is short um it's very useful
to just look at talks that people have
given
uh already or articles they've written
or whatever
so um yeah it's different but i do you
know it's actually
a good it's an interesting philosophical
issue how prepared you want to be
for a podcast you know i definitely i
think in early days
sometimes made the mistake of being over
prepared like i had a view in my mind of
exactly how the conversation was going
to go and maybe i still do that to some
extent but i'm trying to
do that less and less because i think
that you really should be responding
to what the person is actually saying
right and my
role as the interviewer is to play the
role of someone who hasn't read
the book right so you need to read the
book to know enough
about the field to ask some questions
but you
need to know not too much so you don't
try to guide the answers very much
either chris m says do you have a
favorite poker hand that you have played
be it a winning or losing hand is there
one that sort of
stands out for you for one reason or
another ah
i have you know i i i'm not very good at
remembering
this kind of thing you know in in
general my memory is not very good and i
think this is
uh in part maybe this is a two-clip
explanation but i'm a forward-thinking
person so i care more about the future
than the past so i'm terrible at memory
remembering all sorts of things
um plots of novels or movies and so
forth and poker hands
included so the really good poker
players will tell you you know
every hand in a tournament that they
played five years ago and i i'm
lucky if i remember many at all there
are some that stick out you know for for
both positive and negative reasons like
one that i will never forget
i was in caesar's palace in las vegas
and i had just
uh busted out of a tournament so
i figured i would play um a ring game as
it's called
so you know for those of you who are not
poker players there's tournaments where
a lot of people come in and gradually
you eliminate until you get a winner and
there's ring games where you know nine
or ten people sit at a table and just
play against each other
people come in and out um as
spaces open up so i entered a ring game
you know i bought i forget what the
buy-in was
a couple hundred dollars i sat down and
the very first hand i got pocket queens
which is an excellent hand to get
and i raised and i got re-raised i
re-raised again
and we were all in uh before the
uh flop came before the extra cards came
and i uh ended up getting i think it was
three of a kind
another queen came down and the other
guy got a straight so literally on my
first hand i lost all my
money on a very good hand that i had so
again i'm not remembering this because i
either played it well or badly it sort
of played itself as you know that's
another thing the poker players
sometimes say like
you didn't have a lot of choices if uh
um
you have a hand that good you're gonna
play it and then sometimes the cards are
against you
i have done other things that were good
um you know uh i've had some success but
i don't really remember you know big
hands in the
in the biggest successful tournaments
i've done it's more like
just not making mistakes is more
important than making doing brilliant
hands
uh i do once i have a i had a
happy event where um i was in a hand it
was a ring game he was not a tournament
and it was one of those speculative
hands where like you know suited
connectors so like five of diamonds
six of diamonds and i had not been doing
that well
and uh two other players um
just kept betting against each other i
just kept calling
and i made a flush on the
last card on the river and they just
kept betting
and my flush was completely disguised
because you know only one other diamond
had fallen
on the flop and i sort of got two more
but and when i won the hand
both of them were outraged they're like
oh man we thought you were a good player
why were you hanging in there with
such a crappy hand but because there
were two other people in there
and because even though my hand was
intrinsically crappy there were many
ways for it to improve
i still had the odds to stay in the
whole way along so
it's a special pleasure you get when you
do the right thing but the other people
at the table think you've done the wrong
thing
and you come away with all the money
samuel berry says
you are both an actively researching
professor and do so much work writing
about and communicating the ideas that
you love
do you have any advice for young
scientists who would love to get more
involved in science writing
but aren't sure how to both be a
practicing scientist and a writer
educator
uh well the simple advice is you if you
want to do that you have to prioritize
being a practicing scientist
first and foremost my short advice would
be
do very little uh outside outreach until
you have tenure
uh if if and it's a big if
if being a tenured professor is the most
important thing to you uh because being
tenured professor is hard i'm not
by the way right so i'm not a good uh
role model here
but um i'm a research professor at
caltech so
it counts as senior faculty but not
technically tenured
but the point is being coming and
getting a 10-year professor job
is hard uh along the way there are many
bottlenecks right there are many more
people who want to be graduate students
than can be there are many more grad
students who want to be postdocs than
can be
many more people who are postdocs who
want to be faculty members who can be
many more people who are faculty members
want to get tenure then can be okay
so they're at every step looking for
reasons to reject you do not hire you to
not promote you and the fact that you
put a lot of
effort into something that is not
research is one of those ways one of
those reasons that they will cease upon
to not promote you or hire you
that is not to say it can't be done
right of course there are
wonderful examples of people who um have
been very very successful at both
but almost always they get tenure first
and they start writing people like you
know
stephen hawking or lisa randall or
stephen weinberg these people were
famous physicists before
they started having a big public profile
so
if you're very very very dedicated to
the idea
of writing and communicating about the
ideas you love to the extent
that you are willing to decrease your
chances of becoming a tenured professor
then do that
but do it with open eyes that's my only
bit of advice the you know there's no
certainties in this game you know if
you're a genius
uh if you're revolutionizing the field
then you can do whatever you want
they will they will still hire you uh
but for most of us we have to maximize
our chances
cheyenne says i was wondering if you do
an episode with my friend and former
boss hui
g ma professor of psychology and
neuroscience at nyu
uh maybe you know happy to take
suggestions thanks for the suggestion
eric skoglen says do you have a top five
philosophy books everyone interested in
it should read um so let me give you
some preliminary
waffling answer here first i'm not that
fond of this kind of question i think
i'm going to get it again later in the
in the q a like top five or you know
biggest uh
best of list or whatever that's just not
how i think about
these things you know my own education
whether it's physics or philosophy
doesn't come from a top set of books it
comes from all over the place i'm very
you know haphazard
and grab you know bits of information
here and there kind of person
um and and like i said before my memory
is not that good so it's very possible i
read a book and it was very influential
on me and i've forgotten that i read it
um so but having said that that's all
the preliminary throat clearing um
you know i'm not sorry that's not all
the preliminary thing let me do some
more preliminary throat clearing
there was a recent kerfuffle on
philosophy twitter
about um the importance of reading
the great works of philosophy in the
original
right primary sources rather than
secondary sources do you
need to read kant and hegel and so forth
or
can you get the best of their ideas from
secondary sources
and it was a legitimate conversation
because there you know there's one side
that says look
you have to be able to read the primary
sources otherwise you're not a real
philosopher otherwise you're not
engaging with the best opinions and
ideas that we have
in their original form there's another
side which i guess i'm more
sympathetic to as a scientist which says
if what you care about are the ideas
then those ideas should be expressible
by people other than the people who came
up with them
indeed in science generally and
certainly in physics it's almost always
the case
that we get better and better at
expressing ideas as we understand them
more and more uh so reading sec like
nobody
in physics reads galileo or newton or
maxwell right
that's just if you have an interest in
the history of physics you can do that
but no working physicist thinks that
that's their job
whereas in philosophy it's very much the
other side all of which is to say
my favorite philosophy books are not the
classics right i mean i like some of
them you know
david hume i like lucretius you know
aristotle is always interesting to read
for very different reasons people like
um nietzsche
are interesting to read um but i've
never really read contour hegel as
those two examples would be plato plato
of course is a lot of fun to read
but most of my philosophical education
for what it's worth comes from more
modern
sources one way or the other in that
world more modern sources again it
depends on
do you want you know a work of original
philosophy or do you want
some something more pedagogical you know
in what i do
a book like david albert's time and
chance
is what i would consider to be a classic
um david albert former podcast guest
where we talked about quantum mechanics
but he also
indeed probably his most important
contribution is
in thermodynamics and the arrow of time
and his book time and chance
is the classic statement of that it's
the kind of book where
20 years later you have a series of
essays devoted to
the legacy of time and chance right
because i wish i know because i just
contributed to such a volume
and david of course if you listen to the
podcast he has a very
particular specific way of speaking that
some people love
and some people can't stand and i'm here
to tell you that his way of speaking is
a hundred percent carried over to his
writing
it sounds exactly like him speaking and
so if you
like that you will love it and if you
don't you won't
um on the more pedagogical side of
things
uh i've recently read a wonderful book
by david pepino who is a
philosopher i think king's college
london he's in london anyway
called philosophical devices and if
you're interested in
sort of modern philosophy in
a digestible form i can't do better than
to recommend philosophical devices
because basically he talks about
the big ideas in analytical philosophy
analytic philosophy
um in a very clear but very very concise
form so he talks about set theory and
numbers but he
also talks about probability uh and he
talks about things like causation
and necessity and uh reference and
naming
and all the big ideas in modern analytic
philosophy
hopefully but maybe there's a similar
book in continental philosophy but i
wouldn't know
uh specifically what daniel fox
says given that predation is sort of
baked into evolution as a more efficient
means of creating genetic diversity and
energetic organisms
do you think that perhaps with the
advent of advanced gene editing we can
slowly move away from the aggression and
violence
that predation engenders well um
we can yeah if you're if your question
is can we which it technically was
then yes probably we could you know we
could um
mess with people's with the with the
genome remember this is what
everyone who comes on the show i've had
people come on the show like fiornov or
carl zemmer who thought about these
things they're all very much against
what is called
germline editing right so
fixing or improving if you want
parts of the human genome to be passed
on to future generations
as opposed to just you know removing
diseases or something like that
but it might happen and i think you know
as ornov said uh probably will happen
whether we like it or not it's just
going to become too easy to do it
so my thought if if the hidden question
that you're asking is
are we going to do this i think that's
not the right way to think about it i
think that it's going to become
common to edit people's genomes
and different people will do it in
different ways some people will edit
so the people who are born are more
aggressive and violent
some will do it who are less and
natural selection will still play its
games uh still
work its wheels turn the turn the wheels
of uh selection
on those people whoever they are so i do
think that
it's really going to have a huge impact
on the future of humanity that that much
i'm clear but i think it's very very
difficult
to predict exactly what the direction of
that effect will be
steve pelling says it could be a bit of
a stupid question but
could there maybe be some link between
adscft
the holographic principle and brain
theory b-r-a-n-e
all of these seem to share a common
theme of reality being constructed in
the space based on a fundamentally
different number of spatial dimensions
um so yes that is not a stupid question
in fact the answer is
clearly yes there's a hundred percent um
a link
between adscft the holographic principle
and brain theory and the
the very brief history of it is the
holographic principle came
first um late 80s early 90s maybe early
90s
it toughed and suskinned from different
ways of thinking about black holes
suggested the holographic principle that
we could think about
the information that encodes what's
happening in a black hole
as being distributed on its
two-dimensional event horizon rather
than its three-dimensional
volume um then brain theory
came along people like joe balczynski
and others
realized that there were these things
called d brains
and you could be stuck on the brain
right you know the fields that make up
the standard model or whatever some
other
model you were just inventing would be
confined to a brain even though it was
embedded in extra dimensions
and then the adscft correspondence came
about because juan maldasena
was thinking about you know stacks of
brains that sort of created a black hole
and he realized that if you go to if you
do this in a certain way you stack a
bunch of brains on top of each other
and you go take a certain limit of a
certain region of the
resulting space time it looks like
anti-dissider space
and so he invented the adscft
correspondence
on the basis of using brain theory and
then
people realized in fact ed whitton uh
made it very very super explicit
that this was obviously the holographic
principle at work whitton's famous paper
uh
right after maldocenus is called ads
anti-dissider space and holography um i
mean multisenior's paper has the worst
title in the history of titles it's
something like the large end limit of
n equals four supergravity or something
like that i'm not going to remember
exactly what it was called but it gives
you no
clue that it's about ads cft in the
modern way of thinking about things and
it went on to be the most highly cited
paper of all time so that tells you
how important it is to get a good title
namely maybe not at all if you have a
brilliant idea
stefan lyon says at age 25 i find myself
having a quarter life crisis about the
faustian bargain of working in corporate
america
do you think there are opportunities in
the academic research side of physics
for people who do not have graduate
degrees in physics
but bring separate technical skill sets
like data modeling and visualization to
the table
well there absolutely are um but you
know you have to think
carefully about what that would mean so
in theoretical physics and the part that
i know
about and do myself there aren't roughly
speaking
um in order to do the kind of
theoretical physics that i like doing
you need essentially a graduate level
education
in the very specific field that you're
working in
i mean 25 you're not dead yet you still
have time you could get a graduate level
education in theoretical physics or
anything else if you wanted to
but theoretical physicists don't need
big teams they don't need a lot of data
modeling or visualization they just need
pencil and paper
now there are on the other hand
experimental physicists
and observational astrophysicists that
work on very big
data sets on huge experiments and there
they have a much not only a bigger team
but the team is not all phd physicists
uh there's plenty of other people
who work on those uh experiments and so
in that kind of thing in places where
you have big data
involved you can absolutely make a
contribution
to physics astrophysics
biophysics condensed matter physics
particle physics gravitational wave
physics all of those things
are definitely ways that you could in
principle make a
make a career out of doing that beyond
that in more specifics i'm not the
person to ask because i don't do it
myself but
uh yes those opportunities are there
gabor peter sur
says these days there is a loud group of
anti-vaxxers pandemic skeptics fat
earthers etc
according to you what is the best way to
strengthen trust in science
um short answer is i'm not sure i don't
i don't have a
a simple plan to put forward uh
in that direction i have opinions though
which i which i tend to do
you know i think that a lack of trust in
science
usually doesn't have that much to do
with science uh it usually has a lot
more to do with trust
i think that it's one aspect of
a lack of trust in elite institutions
and opinions
and science is one of those but it's not
the only one
and i think that so the question to ask
is why don't people trust
institutions more generally than that
right
what leads people to conspiracy theories
and
um denial of scientific consensus and
things like that
and you know that's a good question and
i don't know the answer i mean
economics has something to do with it uh
political power has something to do with
it the world is changing very fast and
scary has something to do with it
failures in our educational system have
something to do with it
so i don't think there is a simple
answer but you know
we can all do our little part to make
science seem more trustworthy
justin bailey says would you describe a
paradox that would occur
if you could receive information faster
than light i can see how i would have
knowledge of the future
but i don't see how i could create a
paradox such as preventing my
grandparents from meeting or similar
well i think you know the thing you're
referring to is the idea that
if you can send information faster than
light
then according to the rules of
relativity that is equivalent to being
able to send it backward in time
um there's no simple division of the
universe into past present and future
there's
past future and space like separated
so if you can move in space-like ways
then you can travel into the future just
as well as into the past
so if that's true it's not just that you
can receive
information from the future you can send
information to the past
so you can send information to your
grandmother saying don't marry that guy
and if for whatever reason you're
convincing then you could cause a
paradox
uh i'm not sure what that's what you're
asking but i think that's all that's all
i can
come up with for an answer doug c says
do we all travel through space-time at
the speed of light and if so can you
explain this in an intuitive way
um no i don't think that's right i don't
think we travel through space time at
the speed of light and i
need to give a nitpicky answer to this
um
when you talk about traveling and speeds
you're specifically already talking
about travel through
space not through space-time right
what is a speed a certain number of
kilometers per hour or
kilometers per second or whatever right
so that means just by the definition of
what a speed is
it means a certain amount of space that
you traverse
in a certain amount of time and in a
certain reference frame
or with respect to some standard of
observation
you can measure your speed you're not
moving you're moving at
one percent the speed of light you're
moving the speed of light whatever
there's no such thing as trav as the
speed through which you travel through
space-time
okay it's just not that's not a sensible
concept the closest you could come
is to ask how much time is elapsed
or what is the space-time interval that
is traversed
along some path that you might take
through space-time
and because we all move slower than the
speed of light
through space space-time interval that
we traverse will be
time-like it will be measured in units
of time not of space
so really you're asking how much time
passes
as we move through space-time and the
answer is always one second per second
which is not the speed of light right
the speed of light is one light year per
year or one light second per second
because that is literally a speed
through space there's no such thing as a
speed through time and if there was it
would be one second per second which
would be one which is just silly
adam baz says do you see any issues with
the treatment of the general concepts of
religion as an emergent phenomenon
in the sense that they are real but only
to the degree
that they allow humans to talk about or
make predictions about their behavior
and orient themselves in ways that are
evolutionarily
favorable over long time spans um
i don't think that's the right way of
thinking about it to be honest like if
you think about
i'm not sure what you mean by the
general concepts of religion
let's say the existence of god or the
idea that uh
jesus died for our sins or that there's
an afterlife okay
to me these are factual claims about
reality they could be true or they could
be false
um they don't explain anything uh unless
they are they are actually
existent it's not like that there is a
difference between fundamental and
emergent
but both fundamental things and
immersion things are real
um but there's also a distinction
between real
and false true and you know truly
existing and real
and not existing right unicorns
uh in the usual way of thinking about
things are not real they're not emergent
they just don't exist
and to me the concepts of religion are
likewise
like that now you can say um but wait a
minute
unicorns are used in part of our
explanation for certain human behaviors
you know like putting up stickers of
unicorns on our
uh that doesn't make them real that mean
that makes the concept of a unicorn
real but doesn't make unicorns real so
the concept of an afterlife or god or
jesus or whatever
the concepts are all real in the sense
that there exist people who have those
concepts in their heads
and you absolutely need to take account
of the existence of those concepts to
make sense of their behavior right i did
this because i think that jesus would
have liked me to do it
that has no bearing whatsoever on
whether jesus
actually is was real or jesus is really
the son of god or anything like that he
had to distinguish between those two
things
john box says what is your take on model
dependent realism as described by
hawking and vladinov in the grand design
is this a popular view among physicists
um you know i don't think so for those
of you who haven't read stephen hawking
and leonard wodnav
had this idea in their book the grand
design called model dependent realism
which you know says well what we call
really existing depends on the model we
use to describe
the world so for example i'm not
completely sure this is an example
because i'm not
completely sure that i understand what
they meant um
in ads cfd right when you have uh two
different quantum mechanical theories
one is a field theory in four dimensions
and the other is a theory of quantum
gravity in five dimensions
and you say but they're really the same
theory they really describe the same
physical situation so if you ask what is
real is it really the field theory is it
really the gravity theory
there's no answer to that it's either
one is perfectly okay
um so i think that the basic idea
of this is pretty amenable pretty pretty
acceptable
to most physicists who think about
foundational physics you know quantum
field theory uh space time kind of
things like that
i don't you know philosophers have put a
lot of work into this
uh and hawking vladimir did not read any
of them or anything like that so
the idea of all dependent realism has
some
aspects of truth to it it's not a very
sophisticated way
of asking these questions to be honest
which doesn't mean it's wrong
right i mean it can be mostly true but a
more sophisticated
version of it would sort of fix up the
ways in which it might
fail you know make a little bit more
precise and rigorous and stuff like that
so
i would not turn to the grand design for
my best way of thinking about what is
real and what is not real let's put it
that way
paul cooper says how do physicists know
that the hubble expansion and black hole
event horizons
and so forth are the same for all
observers as i understand it
time moves more slowly as you go more
deeply into the well of a gravitational
field
a clock on the surface of the earth runs
slow relative to a clock in orbit
and there's more to that i'm just
condensing the question a little bit
um yeah you know and i think i think
we've answered questions like this
before
or at least i have maybe not in ama form
but um
you know there's very very often and a
set of assumptions
that physicists are making when they
talk about things in cosmology or in
relativity
that they don't always make explicit so
when we say something like the age of
the universe
right the universe is approximately 13.8
billion years old since the big bang
and people always want to say well but
wait a minute
relativity tells me that the elapsed
time depends on how i move through the
universe and the answer is
sure it does and in fact when we say
the universe is approximately 14 billion
years old we mean
as measured in the reference frame of
someone who is essentially stationary
with respect to galaxies uh or the
microwave background there is a
reference frame being picked out
um the hubble expansion rate is a real
physical thing
you know um so i'm not exactly sure
which which of these questions you're
asking so i'm gonna give a whole bunch
of different answers
the hubble expansion rate is a real
physical thing the light we
receive from distant galaxies
is observed at a different wavelength
than it was emitted because then we know
what it was emitted at because
that's a question of atomic physics not
of cosmology
uh so there is something that is
universal called the hubble expansion
rate there is something that is
universal called the
age of the universe these are um
maybe measured with respect to some
universally understood reference frame
but they're really
things likewise the black hole event
horizon a black hole event horizon is
a point of no return if you're inside
the event horizon you cannot escape
to the outside world if you're outside
you can that is absolutely true for all
observers
anonymous says suppose i understand
functions
rn so31 you know a bunch of mathematical
things
but not tensors or differential geometry
do i have the tools to understand the
mathematical structures of a gauge
theory in minkowski space
i could understand 4d spacetime calling
boosts the global phase shifts
equivalent to something like r4 modulo
the lorentz group or something like that
but that doesn't seem local or gagey
enough
well so again i struggle to know exactly
what it is you mean
if you understand that much math then
you can pick up
the other math you need you know you
absolutely need
tensors to understand
the conventional presentations of gage
theories in kelsey space
yes why well forget about you know
fancy things like the strong
interactions qcd or whatever
electromagnetism is invented by maxwell
back in the 1850s actually when when did
he put the finishing touches i don't
know
but the modern way we understand
electromagnetism
uh takes the electric field and the
magnetic field and combines them in
something called the electromagnetic
field strength tensor
f mu nu so you need to know a little bit
about tensors uh
to do that but so what it's easy to pick
up it's really not that hard if you know
these other things you can just learn
what you
need to know so i think that a lot of
people who haven't yet studied advanced
physics have this idea
they need to learn the math first and
then
they'll have no trouble just going
through the physics but almost
everyone who understands these things
just picks up the math as they need it
because the purpose is different if
you're a mathematician
you're learning the math in order to
prove theorems but physicists don't care
about proving theorems they just want to
know what's true
which which you know i'm joking about it
but is way easier than proving theorems
so the kinds of math you need
to understand gauge theories or particle
physics you can absolutely pick up as
you learn them and almost any good
field theory textbook will teach them to
you
wes clyburn says if any what novels have
you re-read the most
during your life um so probably
i was trying to think about that uh
caveats about memory
uh taken in red onto the record here
um probably the ones i've read most of
my life are the ones that i started
reading a long time ago right when i was
a kid when i first read when i was young
when i was reading mostly science
fiction and so it's probably
either going to be robert heinlein's the
moon is a harsh mistress
or roger zelazny's lord of light i think
that
these are clearly two books that i've
read multiple times many times
um slightly later in life i stumbled
across pride and prejudice by jane
austen and i've read that many times
since then so it's possible that pride
and prejudice uh has taken the lead but
certainly it started out
behind um very different obviously pride
and prejudice than
lord of light or who's harsh mistress
but you know
they all have their charms in different
ways
simon carter says i recently read about
david deutch and his theory about
shore's algorithm
seemingly proving many worlds by the
fact that it can factor a number greater
than the amount of atoms in our universe
what is your take on this
uh you know i think it's clearly true
that
nothing about quantum computation proves
many worlds
why what is the proof well because you
can derive all the results of quantum
computation without many worlds being
true
like the results of quantum computation
are just as true
in pilot wave theories or dynamical
collapse theories or epistemic theories
as they are in many worlds
i think that the uh you know quantum
computers
are an example of something as we
mentioned earlier in the ama
maybe you can make the sense that make
the case they make more
sense from a many world's perspective
but calculation you get the same answer
no matter what
choice you're using bill goss
says i'm 67 years old let's assume i'm
lucid for 25 more years
which of any of the following do you
think are likely in that time period
a confirmation of alien life elsewhere
in the solar system
b experimental proof of the source of
dark matter see
an empirically credible theory of
quantum gravity
um yeah these are all interesting
questions because you could make a case
either way for the next 25 years it's a
reasonable time scale
um you know i mean i think that if there
exists life elsewhere in the solar
system i presume you mean not
life from other planets that came life
from other star systems that came here
but like life
on mars or europa or titan or whatever
enceladus
um if it's there i think there's a very
good chance we'll find it in 25 years
but i don't know if it's there
that's something that i i truly have no
strong opinion about
uh experimental proof of the source of
dark matter i i would have said
is um the most promising uh if you asked
me 10 years ago but you know we've been
looking for it and haven't found it
which means that it's more likely now
than then that
the dark matter is one of the things
that is hard to find uh axions
would be hard to find but probably we
could find them in 25 years but
it also raises raises the credence on um
some other candidate that is very very
difficult to find even in 25 years so
that is probably less likely now than it
used to be
empirically credible theory of quantum
gravity that is
i want to guess that one it seems um a
little bit audacious but they're all
audacious
and you know i think that
we're we're getting some progress
i really do think that we're making some
progress in quantum gravity in ways that
are a little bit more
tangible than what we've seen in looking
for dark matter of course we're making
great progress and looking for life in
the solar system but we don't know if
it's there or not we know
that there is some theory of quantum
gravity so i'm going to guess that
that's the most likely
philip blockish says if there was no
decoherence
how would conscious entities like humans
perceive the world
alternatively what would the world look
like to us if our consciousness emerges
from a handful of elementary particles
such that the coherence plays no
significant role
um i don't know the actual answer to
this i don't even have an intelligent
answer to
guess at but let me point out that i i
am completely convinced that
consciousness cannot arise just from a
small number of particles
um what i don't know is whether or not
you could get
something you would call consciousness
if you didn't have a classical limit
if the world were fundamentally quantum
mechanical in a way that
could never be helpfully described
classically
i'm not sure if you could get what you
and i would recognize as conscious
behavior
maybe i would lean towards saying yes
but
i don't know enough about how that would
even work to
say with great confidence one way or the
other
certainly it'll be very very very
different let's put it that way
jochem says can you summarize jeremy
england's thermodynamic argument for
evolution of complex
complex adaptive adaptive systems in a
tweet
uh so again short answer is no in fact
i'm not even sure
what precisely you're referring to
thermodynamic argument for evolution of
complex
adaptive systems you know in some sense
um
it's a little bit weird you know the the
the ideas that jeremy has had
that have garnered the most public
attention
are the ideas that to me are most
obviously true like of course
entropy is increasing and of course
nevertheless complex structures arise
we know that uh in it's pretty obvious
that those complex structures make use
of the entropy gradients you know roger
penrose wrote about that
um in his book and he's just a physicist
the
biologists have certainly known this for
a long time what's interesting
interesting about jeremy's um arguments
is that he has some specific mechanisms
by which structures can you know hold
together um
uh either by absorbing energy or by
emitting energy or fail to hold together
and just reflect the energy
and some other arguments about the
efficiency of thermodynamic engines and
things like that so in my mind you know
the important thing that he's done is
the is the detailed work more than some
sweeping tweet length argument
paul hess says what does the term
geometrical degeneracy mean
in the context of talking about the cmb
and determining whether or not we lived
in curved or flat
space it's just a way of saying that
if all you measure if i'm understanding
it correctly if all you measure the cmb
just like if you measure any other
single cosmological observable
you're trying to determine many
parameters from one data set right
you're trying to constrain the hubble
constant and the geometry of space
and the amount of dark energy and the
amount of dark matter and all these
different things
a degeneracy in that is well i can
change
the geometry of space but i could change
other things like the hubble constant
and the dark energy
to compensate so that the cmb would look
the same there's no guarantee in other
words
you can measure one thing like the cmb
and from that pin down
all the cosmological observables
independently
michael will says who do you think would
win in a fight between leonard huskin
and lee smolin
mma rules um not sure never seen either
one of them fight i'm going to guess
lenny suskind just because lee seems
like such a soft-spoken guy
uh whereas lenny seems like a little
more rough and tumble uh by nature but
you know
these are the kind of things you have to
do the experiment i don't know set it up
marcelo ligouri says would you ever
consider having an objectivist
i presume that's in the ann randian
sense as a guest to discuss
proper role of government um you know
you never know
but i go by actual people um you name
some names but i didn't recognize either
one of those names so
you know when when a good name comes
along who has something that i think
would be um interesting to hear about
then i will always be open to have them
on the podcast
jared kasulich says if someone were
starting their journey into physics
how would you recommend they start are
there areas that would provide a high
return on their investment in the short
term
with regard to understanding the world
are there areas that with enough effort
someone might be able to make a
contribution to the field in a five to
ten year
time frame well it depends on where
you're starting your journey
from you know most
working physicists spent four years as
undergraduates and roughly five or six
years as graduate students
and while graduate students they can
make contributions to the field so most
working physicists start from
a high school education and make
contributions in a 10-year time frame
yeah that there you go um i'm not quite
sure
where to start i mean there's you know
there's a there's a wonderful web page
by gerard de tuft where he
goes through the whole curriculum that
you need to be a theoretical physicist
in fact it's a very very ambitious
version of the curriculum i've often
thought about like making a stripped
down version
but i think it's pretty basic stuff you
know you start with classical mechanics
and then you
do e m and relativity and statistical
mechanics
and uh quantum mechanics and field
theory you know this
i think it's a pretty standardized
curriculum you can find just about
anywhere
duncan palmer says after your podcast
with ned hall you seem to be
reconsidering your position along the
human anti-human spectrum
have you resolved your position since
that conversation um
not really i'm still uh you know if you
put a gun to my head
still pretty humid about things
i do think there's certain kinds of
questions where if you're anti-human
the answers seem more natural but i'm
not convinced those are good questions
right i mean sometimes we can trick
ourselves into asking questions that
make
sort of grammatical sense and seem to
make sense and as an ordinary natural
language thing
but we realize aren't good questions you
should be asking about the world
as i said before last month i'm thinking
about the philosophy of mathematics
right now so that is forcing me to you
know really confront these
issues so ask me again in a couple
months we'll see where i land
john eastman says could atoms be
shrinking rather than space expanding
and then some more elaboration there
so sure they could be but you have to
realize what it would require
right i mean the you know if you watch
my
biggest ideas in the universe videos i
did a video on scale
where i explain why atoms have the size
they do you know it's not just a random
number
it's set by other constants of nature
the mass of the electron
the charge of the electron and the fine
structure constant in particular
and the fine structure constant you know
can also be thought of as
the speed of light plus the strength of
electromagnetism
etc so if you want to use a
sort of system of measures in which
atoms are shrinking around the universe
is expanding
you have to maintain consistency with
the fact that the sizes of atoms are set
by particle physics
so what you need to do is assume that
all those other constants of nature
speed of light find structure constant
etc are also changing
in such a way that the relative you know
distances of spectral lines and stuff
like that remains the same
so it's overwhelmingly more convenient
to say that space is expanding
than to say that atoms are shrinking
will s
says do you believe laplace's demon can
precisely calculate the future in the
past
is that because you were a many worlds
adherent um
well places deemed as a thought
experiment the boss's demon doesn't
exist just footnote just so everyone
uh knows that but so this is basically
equivalent to saying uh is the universe
deterministic in the sense that based on
information about its current state
its future and past are both determined
my favorite theory of quantum mechanics
is the many worlds interpretation
and in many worlds uh the evolution is
deterministic so
yes in that sense there are also other
versions of quantum mechanics that are
also deterministic like pilot wave
theories and so forth
but until we know for sure you know we
should be a little bit open-minded about
that but my view is it's probably
deterministic
lothian 53 says what do you think of
roger penrose's eon concept so roger
penrose as we discussed very briefly in
our my podcast with him a while ago
he has what is called a conformal cyclic
cosmology
model and in that model the universe
expands for a long time
very very very long time which he calls
it eon and then
uh some magic happens a miracle occurs
and the universe turns back into the big
bang and so then it cycles through eons
after he ends after eons
i'm not a fan honestly i don't think it
solves the arrow of time problem
i don't like that magic has to occur
that there's no physical mechanism
with equations of motion that tells you
how this transition happens
etc so all in favor of clever people
pursuing um ambitious new ideas but that
one is not very compelling to me i think
we can do better than that
phil elloria says curious about your
view on the anti-realist argument
the pessimistic meta-induction of
science
i believe based on past comments you're
a realist about science you seem to
think that physics is telling us
something about the real world
do you find the argument to be a good
one
um i'll be super duper honest i've heard
of this
argument i think larry louden was a
proponent of it
um but i'm not super familiar with it so
i'll probably botch it
the idea roughly as i recall is that you
know our
past attempts at understanding the world
newtonian mechanics classical mechanics
aristotle maxwell whatever have all
eventually been superseded by better
theories in other words in some sense
they've been wrong and therefore our
present theories are probably wrong
but that might be a wrong remembrance of
the argument but to the extent that it's
accurate
that's completely unconvincing to me
because those theories are not wrong
they're right
in a certain regime of applicability a
certain domain
just like i expect our current theories
to be right in a certain domain of
applicability
and then that domain of applicability
will come to an end
and probably does not include all of
reality but it captures
something true about reality so i'm
quite optimistic in that sense about
realism
mike briggs says how much overlap is
there between these three professions
astronomer astrophysicist and
cosmologist
well you know astronomer and
astrophysicist are terms that are used
more or less
interchangeably um sometimes some people
try to draw a distinction between them
astronomers are a little bit more
observational
astrophysicists a little bit more
theoretical but you know there are
departments there are astronomy
departments that churn out
theorists and experimenters and
observers as well as physics departments
so i kind of
don't make a big deal out of the
difference between those two words
cosmology is a subfield within
astrophysics
in maybe you could say a subfield within
physics
but definitely at the overlap of those
two things so cosmology is specifically
the whole world the whole universe
at once right or parts of the universe
that are big enough to be comparable to
the size of the universe so maybe
galaxies or clusters of galaxies and
above
is cosmology if you study star formation
then you certainly are an astronomer or
astrophysicist but you are not a
cosmologist
david lang says what do you think of
john wheeler's geometro dynamics and the
idea that spacetime is the only existent
of the world
so i usually think of the word geometric
dynamics as just a
synonym for general relativity now
wheeler did
in which case i think is great but
wheeler did as you alluded to
want to be more ambitious than that and
imagine that things like elementary
particles
could be modeled by wormholes in
space-time
and i think it doesn't quite work you
know we know better now it's quantum
field theory that is that is correct not
wormholes in space-time
that's not to say there's not a role for
wormholes in space-time both
in the podcast with neda engelhardt and
with lenny suskind
we talked about different ways in which
wormholes might be
relevant to the real world and so there
might be it's one of those things where
there might be something of the argument
that is
um accurate and useful or something of
the of the picture i guess
um even though the literal idea that he
had
wasn't quite right kirk briggs says
according to hume's doctrine
the edifice of geometry is nothing but
sophistry and illusion
as a humane how do you reconcile or view
geometry
uh so i don't think that's quite right
actually you know david hume has this
famous quote again i'm not gonna get it
exactly right
but he basically says uh if is a
statement about
uh abstract reasoning like numbers and
and
quantities um or is it empirical like do
you actually go do experiments
and view uh what you see out there in
the world either one of those two things
is okay
roughly the first is math logic
and the second is science right and he
says besides those two things
you're just whistling in the dark you're
just making stuff up right
then that's the sophistry an illusion
but geometry
is part of math right i mean geometry
absolutely would not
be um labeled by david hume as sophistry
and illusion there you go joy kolbeck
says are higgs bosons or other large
particles created
in a black hole um so first a little
footnote when you say higgs bosons are
large particles you know
higgs bosons are massive particles but
again as i think i did in the same exact
uh video the scale video and the biggest
ideas
massive and quantum field theory
particles are actually smaller
okay so they're not large in the extent
of um distance across
right the compton wavelength of a
massive particle is smaller than that of
a
of a mat of a low mass particle um
having okay so having said that the
higgs boson is a massive particle
are they created in a black hole so then
i'm not quite sure what you mean i mean
inside a black hole there's no particles
being created it's just sort of ordinary
physics so probably you don't mean that
there is of course hawking radiation
from
near the event horizon of a black hole
and
usually we think of hawking radiation as
taking the form of photons gravitons
neutrinos very low mass
particles but in principle there will be
some high mass particles in that
radiation that is given off but the way
to think of it is
there's a temperature for the radiation
right and if the mass of your particle
is much bigger in natural units than the
temperature
then a very very very small fraction of
your particles are going to be
that massive particle so a big a black
hole that is anywhere near astrophysical
size
has a very very low temperature of
hawking radiation so basically
zero mass particles can be emitted but
it won't even be emitting
electrons and positrons in any
noticeable numbers much
less very heavy particles like top
quarks or higgs bosons but in principle
they could be there
sandro stuckey says why is it that we
get to assume that every microstate
compatible with a given macrostate is
equally probable
i kind of agree with david albert in
your conversation with him that invoking
the principle of indifference seems
dubious
the way he put it in the debate david
and i had a debate that he can find
online about
everetty and quantum mechanics the way
david put in the debate was something
like this if you tell me there are five
boxes
out of which one contains a marble and
you ask me what the chances are
the marble is in the first box i really
don't have any reason to say 20
unless i know something about how the
marbles got into the boxes
um yeah and i think that david's wrong
about that i disagree uh but
you know let's be a little bit clear
because there's the general question of
how you reason
under uh situations of incomplete
information
and the specific question about how you
reason in statistical mechanics
in statistical mechanics where you have
you know microstates and macrostates and
you
you derive thermodynamics and so forth
then we
make when you say your question is why
is it we get to assume that every
microstate
is equally probable well we get to
assume whatever we want
and the question is what works you know
what assumptions pay off
right and so as a matter of fact in
statistical mechanics assuming that
every microstate is equally
probable works so it's one of these
things where it's part of science you
make an assumption then you test it
against your
data um more generally like the
conditions
so you know the thought experiment where
you have the boxes
i think that david is just not playing
fair because you need to do something
you know he's
invented a very um contrived
circumstance someone hands you five
boxes and a marble is in one of the
boxes
um and so someone else might say well
but what if you if they held a gun to
your head
and insisted that you put a probability
on it or insisted that you bet
right but if you were forced to bet
money okay
would you accept four to one odds
against the um
marble being in one box um and that's a
way to sort of
give some heft to your credences about
these different things and david would
say well i think it's just very rude
for people to hold guns to my head or to
force me to bet and i think
that's a little it's a little cheating
like i said because
it's very much like it's essentially
exactly analogous to
the question of how do we think about
the correct
physical theory of the world right how
do we think about
science you know what is the dark matter
okay so is it
an axion or is it weakly interacting
mass particle or whatever
um we put credences on that we don't
know
which one it is but um we say well i
think there's probably 50
chance of this 60 chance of that right
and you might think that the cases are
not
quite um analogous because
in one case there's literally boxes in
front of you and someone
put the marble in the box in another
case we're talking about the laws of
physics
but in both cases there's something you
don't know about the world
right and then i would argue that in any
case where there's something you don't
know about the world
if you're interested in getting along in
the world
in living your life you are inevitably
irresistibly unavoidably putting
credences
on things when you walk down a flight of
stairs
you have a credence that the stairs will
not collapse the gravity will not
reverse
its direction and push you away that the
stairs are really there that you're not
a brain in a bat you have credences on
all these things right
you need to to act and to live in the
world
now the importance of having these
credences
is going to be very different from
question to question most people can get
by perfectly well
without having any credences on what the
dark matter is whereas you do need to
have credences on whether gravity
will reverse or not so i think the same
thing is true
in these cases of physics questions i
mean we're asking questions we care
about if if
by assumption you care about what
box the marble is in then you have no
choice but to put credences on the
different possibilities and
i would say if you have no other
information then there are five boxes
then why in the world would you do
anything but put equal credences on them
you're allowed to do whatever you want
you're just like you're allowed to think
that gravity will reverse its direction
at any moment
you know it's a free country but you but
you
and if you're if you're actually sort of
agreeing to play the game
and say well what what do i think is the
most sensible thing to do
then in cases like that it's pretty
obvious what the sensible thing to do is
ben shaw says thoughts on tononi's
integrated information theory
for those of you don't know giulio
chinoni has an idea about the nature of
consciousness based on integrated
information
i'm not an expert myself but i am
skeptical of it you can look up online
scott aronson
who is a previous mindscape guest has
given pretty
dramatic takedowns of in my mind of the
integrated information theory
you know roughly speaking the argument
is the good thing that tanoni has done
and his collaborators is they have
provided a
very clear quantitative criterion
for when something is conscious or not
that's good
right it's a it's a they're not
weaseling out of answering the question
the bad news is that if you just naively
apply
that criterion then a whole bunch of
things are suddenly conscious
and in fact you you know tanoni and uh
christophe [ __ ] also who has sympathies
along these lines
tend towards pan psychism for that very
reason if you listen to the pan psychist
uh
interview i did with philip gough you'll
you'll learn about that
um and to many of us you know some of
these things that qualify as conscious
by
integrating information theory standards
are clearly not conscious
and again the good thing that tanoni
does is bite the bullet he says nope
they are conscious you know this
you know this book just sitting there on
the shelf is actually conscious because
it is by my theory
um but to me it's not capturing what
we're trying to understand about
consciousness
as far as i can tell seamus maxwell says
would you consider recording a solo
podcast while in a really bad mood and
or drunk
i realize this would be a radical
departure but i have a feeling it would
be incredibly compelling
um nope not gonna do that um it may or
may not be
compelling but it would be you know look
i'm not objecting to the idea
uh you know i i would in principle
um do something for entertainment
purposes
but it's not this podcast right
mindscape has a purpose
which is not just to have some laughs
we'd like to have laughs along the way
but uh we like to tackle big issues and
work hard at understanding them
and being in a really bad mood and or
drunk are not conducive to that
particular project that we have here on
the podcast
fran plus says i'm really fond of your
idea that baby universes pinch off from
a multiverse
it's both cool and helps make sense of
the arrow of time and entropy
my question is can the process of
creating baby universes be eternal and
infinite uh yeah the answer is yes
there's no problem that's one of the
good things about this model and it
relies on the fact
that in general relativity the total
conserved quantity whether it's energy
or charge or angular momentum or
whatever
the total conserved quantity of a closed
universe a universe that is sort of
closed in on itself like a
three-dimensional sphere conserved
quantities are all exactly zero
for closed universes um whether it's
energy or charge or anything else
so it doesn't cost anything to make baby
universes you don't run out of resources
because it costs zero resources
to make them so that is very much part
of the charm of that kind of model that
it can go on forever
peter humble says i would like to hear
your thoughts on how well established
from a scientific perspective is the
theory of evolution
i understand it's much leaning much
closer to fact but will we ever be able
to ditch the noun theory when using the
term evolution
so there's two points here one is the
direct answer to your question
uh it's true the theory of evolution um
in broad strokes what darwin said was
correct
now in detail it was not correct he
didn't even know about dna
much less genes or you know mendelian
inheritance or anything like that
he certainly didn't know about things
like horizontal gene transfer or genetic
drift or a million other things
so we have now what we call the modern
synthesis of genetics with darwinian
evolution and now there are some people
as we mentioned
uh with sean b carroll on that podcast
there's some people who even want to
say we need a new synthesis beyond the
modern synthesis but
they're all updates and extension of
darwin's theory of natural selection
it's just true okay but then you also
say will we be
ever able to ditch the noun theory when
using the term evolution
we're not going to ditch that word
because that's just not a thing we do we
don't ditch
words just because theories become
better established
the idea and i know it's very popular
out there the idea there's some
hierarchy of truth
between models and hypotheses and
theories and laws is just wrong
there is no such hierarchy i mean there
are
different levels of credibility and
truthfulness
to different ideas but we do not in any
systematic way
attach words to those ideas based
on how credible or true they are the
standard
model of particle physics is like the
best confirmed thing we have but we
still call it a model we're never going
to call it the standard theory of
particle physics or the standard law of
particle physics right it's called the
standard model it's just its
name whereas newton's law of gravity
is wrong if you get to strong
gravitational fields it doesn't get the
orbit of mercury right
but we're not going to stop calling it
newton's law of gravity okay
so we don't update these words you know
just don't
care about just don't fool yourself into
thinking that the word we use to
describe a scientific idea is meant to
convey
how accurate or truthful that idea is
it's not how scientists talk
ashley hyatt says will we will any
particles of matter
exist in the far future of the universe
and if so doesn't this imply that
maximum entropy won't ever be reached
so this is a tricky sort of subtle
question you know
we're assuming here let's assume that
the universe will expand forever as if
we have a cosmological constant because
if it collapses then the far future
doesn't get reached right if the
universe expands forever and lasts
forever
then there's a theorem bob wald proved
what we call the cosmic no-hair theorem
that the universe empties out
and asymptotically approaches empty
space
okay now so what that means is if you
have some set of particles
that have a you know there's a fixed
number of particles right like
um protons in in the world or something
like that which is not quite fixed
because
you can uh combine with a electron to
make a neutron and maybe protons decay
and whatever but let's imagine the
protons live forever
okay the number of protons in the
universe is roughly constant
but the universe is expanding and the
size of the observable universe in light
years or megaparsecs or whatever unit
you want to use
remains constant even though the
universe expands the size of the horizon
in an accelerating universe in the
universe with a cosmological constant
the size of the part of the universe you
can observe
attains a fixed value in real
units in light years or parsecs and what
that means is
if space is expanding with a fixed
number of particles and
observers in the universe only have
access to a fixed volume of that
universe
the probability that there's even one
particle
in any one particular observable patch
of the universe
goes to zero so particles will exist in
this particular very specific scenario
we've sketched out
but the density of particles approaches
zero the probability you'll bump into a
particle approaches zero
so for all intents and purposes at that
point you've reached maximum entropy
nathan simmons says you get to assemble
the genius team to work on whatever
problem you want say quantum gravity
what historical figures would you choose
to work on that problem
with um so this is this is like is why i
said before that we're going to get top
10 lists uh
in this ama this is kind of like you
know the favorite books
uh question you know favorite physicist
working on quantum gravity
you know i i think that it stems from
i want to say misapprehension but let's
just say this isn't the way i think
okay i do not think that uh isaac newton
for example
who i do think uh accomplished more
than any other physicist in history
would necessarily be the best person
think about quantum gravity
uh he was the best person at that time
to think about classical mechanics for
a whole bunch of reasons i have no idea
whether he'd be any good at thinking
about quantum gravity i mean he
certainly had some mathematical and
physical talent
he was also a little loopy in other ways
um
so i i just don't know you know i think
that honestly in
in a hundred percent honesty um
if you chose the best five physicists in
history
and brought them to the present day and
educated them about
um modern physics and said work on
quantum gravity
and i got to pick an all-star team of
five people working on quantum gravity
right now who are alive i would i would
place
heavy odds that my team would make more
progress than yours
uh because those are my team is made of
people who've been selected to be good
at working on quantum gravity
right so i think that's a more important
criterion
santiago torres says do you foresee your
holiday season plans being different
this year due to covet 19.
uh yeah uh we're not traveled anywhere
we haven't gone anywhere
um remember i did a uh little speaking
tour in australia and new zealand
that was uh just before the
lockdown or you know the pandemic really
hit and i haven't been on an airplane or
an airport since then and so usually i
go to visit my mom in florida
and we're not doing that this year i
think the holidays are going to be bad
i think that you know as i uh record
this
on november 1st numbers are already
ticking upward
thanksgiving and and the christmas
holiday is going to make things much
worse
and if you don't have to i would not
intentionally make a choice to spend a
lot of time in airports and
airplanes it's not the worst possible
thing you can do but it's just
an extra little bit of risk that you
uh can you should avoid if you can would
be my
thought saurage version says
quantum experiments that suggest time
travel was achieved report in the media
do they actually do a time travel as in
particles traveling to their past states
or do they just appear
so because of the math i'm not exactly
sure which
reports you're talking about but nothing
has actually traveled backward in time
in any reasonable sense of the word
maybe they appear so because of math
more likely someone tried to write a
very provocative headline
or press release what can i say gregory
kusnick says
imagine a touring complete cellular
automaton
implemented by a population of enzymes
that bind to specific sites on the free
end
of a vast bundle of protein strands and
attach new amino acids in accordance
with the rules of the cellular automaton
now let's run bostrom's ancestor
simulation on that computer the protein
crystal we end with
is the block universe of the simulated
world with each layer embodying the
state of the world at some moment in
time in all moments equally real
how should we think about the simulated
people embedded in that crystal is there
some sense in which
their subjective experience remains real
even as the crystal sits passively
on the shelf um this is
i can tell you've worked hard on this
question and
good you did a good job this is a this
is in the in the
vicinity of what i consider to be a
very very puzzling difficult question
which is um let me let me phrase it as a
puzzle rather than as a question
on the one hand everything that i would
think about as being characteristic of
consciousness
or experience depends very very
importantly on time passing
right it is not a static thing you know
what i it means to be conscious is
a whole bunch of criteria all of which
in one way or the other
heavily depend on the time evolution of
the system okay that's point one
point two is um you can imagine
time being emergent right so this is not
exactly your thought experiment but i'm
mentioning a very similar one you can
imagine in the fundamental laws of
physics the time is not there and time
is
emergent in some sense so it's not there
in the fundamental level but it's there
at some emergent level and the way it
emerges
is that the overall state of the
universe is static but there's a way of
conceptualizing that static universe as
a set of clocks that are in tight
correlation with a set of other things
then we can then
treat those other things just as if they
were evolving in time
okay so and this is what
most people who think about quantum
gravity think might be true
right as i'm not saying it is true
there's a lot of people who think that
time is emergent in exactly this way
so in that sense time is not real but
it's apparent and emergent but what's
really there is something that is
timeless and not evolving
so there seems to be a dilemma there
you're saying on the one hand
i'm saying on the one hand uh everything
that it
is necessary for consciousness to be in
existence depends on
time passing and on the other hand time
is just
emergent if this scenario is true so you
might want to say
okay well i buy both of those and time
is emergent and it's still
it it's emergent enough uh to count as
creating consciousness but then on the
third hand you say well
then you do your thought experiment
gregory you say well then why can't i
just
make something which even though time is
passing for me
it is just sitting there statically and
it has the structure of what you would
call
a static system where time emerges
within it
isn't there consciousness going on in
there in some sense right i think that
that's my version of your question so i
think this is a very good question
and i'm not quite sure the best way to
answer it the the
intuition i have is that there is
a way of thinking about this static
crystal that you've constructed
in which conscious experiences are real
uh but the the trick is that
that way is orthogonal literally
to our experience of time and
consciousness right because
our experience of time and consciousness
is in the
time variable that you and i all use
that we measure on our clocks our
wristwatches
whereas if you constructed this static
thing
the sense in which conscious creatures
exist and live
out their lives in that static thing is
only an emergent sense within that thing
it is not the sense of time that you and
i have so i think they can be compatible
both at the same time but
they're in some sense incommensurable
what the
creatures in the crystal has an emerging
experience of consciousness
is just inexpressible and in um
experiential i just made up that word
unexperienceable
by us in our world i'm not sure if that
idea that i just uh sketched out holds
together i haven't thought about it very
deeply
uh it does go back to this question we
just talked about with giulio tinoni's
integrated information theory because
one of the
sets of examples that scott aaronson
brings up are all these static things
you know decks of cards and things like
that that in
in principle could satisfy his criteria
for being conscious
so short answer it's a good question i'm
not quite sure what the answer is
mike dillingham says which book or books
had the most profound
impact on your view of the world and
what was it that changed for you
um i'm going to punt this question too
sorry about that mike
you know for the reasons already
mentioned you know i
i just don't attribute profound
changes in my view of the world to
individual books
and i know that you know sometimes
something can crystallize in you when
you read a certain book or hear a
certain argument or read a certain
article or watch a certain talk or
whatever
but in my view those changes are almost
always predicated on
a whole bunch of other changes that were
less visible that happened earlier right
it's like a phase transition it's like
you know you boil the pot of water and
eventually you see bubbles
but all that invisible work heating up
the water before you see the bubbles is
just as important as the moment the
bubbles
form um so
there you go completely punting on this
question i can't even you know i would
like to fake it i would like to offer
some
books that i could say well this made a
big impact on me but i'm not sure in
good conscience i really can there's
many books i like
and they contribute to my worldview but
profound changes are something that are
harder for me to pinpoint there
neil glue says in one of the recent
podcasts you were asking the guest about
whether university staffer students
should be able to prevent a campus group
from inviting a controversial speaker to
campus for an event private to that
group
it wasn't clear to me what your own
position is on this matter could you say
what you think is the policy university
should use in this situation
yes so that was with teresa beijon we
talked about that
and my own view is that universities or
even
even better subsets of universities
should have
very little veto power
over what other subsets of universities
do
in terms of inviting speakers okay
even if the speakers are really bad i
would like
it to be the case that we have a very
very strong
bias in favor of letting people do all
the stupid stuff that they want to do
if it doesn't bother me it doesn't
bother us if it doesn't bother anybody
else
right but i don't want to make that an
absolute prohibition because i don't
think there's
there are any absolutes in this game at
all to be honest
you can imagine situations in which even
though you were just inviting a speaker
to talk to your group
there were circumstances under which
doing that would bring harm
to other people even who are not in your
group right
and i think that's a good reason to
prevent it so i think that in practice
you know if someone is a nazi or a
racist or whatever and some group on
campus wants to
listen to a talk by them they should be
allowed to do that but i don't want to
put a blanket prohibition
on uh appreciating the nuances of
individual situations
chris shaw says i was wondering does the
big bang start the process or even
before
during inflation i think that there's
some words missing in that
sentence chris but that might be my
misreading or does it even matter do the
wave function hamiltonian vector even
need a cosmological start
um yeah i mean you're going to guess my
answer to this which is nobody knows
we don't know um as i said already
once in this podcast uh the big bang may
or may not have been the beginning
of the universe um inflation was almost
certainly not
the beginning inflation is literally a
physical process that goes on but needs
to start
somewhere um the big bang could
there there could be so forget about the
phrase the big bang which might come
laden
with preconceptions there may or may not
be a beginning
to the universe we don't know and if
there is it could be a sharp beginning
or a fuzzy beginning in other words
the idea of space and time might be
approximations that sort of gradually
kick in
rather than instantly starting we just
don't know sorry
linear mizyara says according to black
hole complementarity
if an astronaut passes through the event
horizon he would not feel anything
special
however according to a distant observer
the infinite time dilation would cause
hawking radiation to kill the same
astronaut
what is going on um so there's no
contradiction here this is the whole
point
of black hole complementarity is that
everything is ultimately consistent even
though different observers use different
languages to
describe it so it is not true in
particular
that to a distant observer um hawking
radiation would appear
to kill the astronaut it's a tricky
thing because you know general
relativity is tricky and
the whole bit is tricky but when you're
a
[Music]
distant observer you see hawking
radiation come from the black hole and
it's at some temperature right there's
some
typical energy in the photons you see
coming from the black hole
and if you just use classical general
relativity and ask
what would that radiation have looked
like if i
hovered just above the black hole
right so if i put on my rocket chip my
rocket engines and i went right to the
event horizon but not quite to cross it
and i fired my rocket engine so i could
just hover above
the event horizon what would that same
hawking radiation look like
and the answer is super energetic super
high temperature
radiation that would emulate you okay
but if you just fall through if you just
freely fall if you do not accelerate to
see
to stay above the event horizon if you
let yourself cross over it
you don't see any hawking radiation
there's it basically turns off as you
approach
the black hole's event or eyes and it
just looks like empty space
and that is what the distant observer
would see the distant observer sees
radiation
but they don't see high intensity
radiation killing you
because they don't see you hovering
above the event horizon what they would
see is
you crossing the event horizon well what
they would see is you coming closer and
closer to crossing the event horizon
time dilation means they never quite see
you cross it but also remember
and this is what people people people
have heard
that you never see people the informing
observer across the event horizon
because of time dilation what they
either have not heard or have chosen to
forget is
the radiation that you see that would
illuminate that infalling person
i'm not about hawking radiation i'm just
talking about like if you have a
flashlight or whatever
that gets time dilated too so the
radiation that you would
use to see the person falling in is
number one
redshifted every photon gets redder and
redder and redder and therefore if you
have visible light eyeballs you don't
get to see them because they become
infrared or much longer
and number two the number of photons
goes down because the time in between
photons gets longer and longer
attending towards infinitely long so in
practice
you see the person disappear even though
in principle in the classical gr limit
as a point
test particle there you would never
not have them in your past light cone
but you never actually literally see
them across the event horizon
fred alexander says you're fond of
saying such and such is not one of the
top 10 things that keep you up at night
what are the top two or three things
that actually do keep you up at night
another top ten list um
you know i get i'm not very clever about
this particular
question um you know i worry about
politics right now
not just who's going to win the election
but the very idea of democracy
and the fact that so many people don't
value it as much as i do
that bothers me not just in the us but
worldwide
i worry about climate change i worry
about
a whole set of ways in which rapid
technological progress could shake
things up so under that i include
genetic engineering but also artificial
intelligence
um uh brain computer interfaces things
like that
uh biological weapons or you know
pandemics that
are either um uh natural like the one
we're fighting now or artificial in
which case they could be much much
deadlier there's a whole bunch of ways
you know in some sense
the invention of technology has given
humanity enormous leverage
long before it gave us the wisdom to
deal with that leverage we
somehow escaped large-scale nuclear war
in the 20th century there's no guarantee
that we won't have
large-scale nuclear war even small-scale
nuclear war
any day now we can't guarantee that
there's thousands of nuclear weapons out
there
ready to be fired and with every passing
day it becomes
easier for someone who is not a
relatively responsible state actor to
build a nuclear weapon
so plenty of things keep me up at night
i have trouble sleeping happily i have
two cats
that keep me comforted and they purr a
lot and it feels good
brendan hall says i know you're busy
with this great chunky chat of questions
but i was wondering if you would wish my
friend nadia a happy birthday
uh and he goes on to mention that nadia
accepts the everett interpretation of
quantum mechanics
i'm glad you added that brendan in which
case happy birthday nadia i hope you
have an exceptionally good birthday
i'm not quite sure what day it is but
whatever day it is uh
i hope you have a happy birthday this
year and in all the other years
having a happy birthday is a good thing
it's a little day when you can you know
pat yourself on the back for making it
through another year
jonathan park says let's say we have two
quantum entangled particles with the up
down spin of each undefined until
measured
we measure the spin of one and get the
result spin up this means when the spin
of the other is measured it must be down
because the spin of both particles is
undefined before measuring is there a
way to fool the universe by measuring
the spin of both particles at exactly
the same time
so first let me just parenthetically
note
there are different ways for particles
to be entangled so you've
you've chosen something where they're
entangled with opposite spins right
one is up the others down or vice versa
but as we already had earlier in the ama
you could also entangle them so that
both of them had the same spin that's a
different way to be entangled so
there's nothing about the idea of
entanglement that says that spins need
to be opposite that's just a little
aside
um but but the answer is no you cannot
fool the universe
by measuring them at the same time the
rules of quantum mechanics are perfectly
clear
if you measure them at the same time
you'll get two answers that are
compatible
uh it will never be the case you know if
you if you put
the two particles into a superposition
which is entangled in the sense that the
two spins are oppositely aligned
then that is always what you will
measure no matter if you do one first or
the other first
or both at the same time james
says rather than describe our universe
as expanding can't we
describe it as a fixed size with a
matter within it shrinking i have an
easier time to visualize it that
this way i already answered that one
earlier in this ama the answer is you
can
but be very aware of what you're giving
up and the hoops you have to jump
through to make that kind of thing make
sense
bendy bruce says when i learned about
the concept of quantum entanglement it
made me sad
because we could not exploit it to
transfer information however i recently
saw a video about a thing called quantum
teleportation
i wonder if you know anything about this
and whether you're willing to try to
explain it in a way that is somewhat
accessible to an
armchair science fan um i can but
believe me it does not let you transfer
information faster than light
the the thing i don't know why people
don't explain this better to be
perfectly honest but
the thing about quantum teleportation is
it is not better than classical
teleportation
the point is that there are reasons to
think that it should be
harder to move quantum information from
one point to another
namely that when you measure a quantum
system you destroy
the quantum information in it right if a
single spin
is in a superposition of spin up and
spin down
you can't directly measure that you can
prepare it in such a way that you know
it's true
but there's not a measurement you can do
that says yep just like i suspected it's
in a
superposition of spin up or spin down
when you measure the spin you get either
up or down
those are the rules of quantum mechanics
right so
classically it has nothing to do with
teleporting it's just like
moving or let's say faxing something
right you have some information on a
piece of paper
you put it in a machine and you fax it
it reads the information it sends some
data and that information is
reconstituted somewhere else
that's really what we mean you know it's
nothing more elaborate than that
and the problem is that you can't do
that quantum mechanically
you can't read the information send it
somewhere else because you destroy the
quantum state
in the process of reading it so
the whole thing about quantum
teleportation is it's a very very clever
setup that allows you to nevertheless
move quantum information from one point
to another
but it's not instantaneous it is not
faster than light
and it is less effective than classical
teleportation what you need to be able
to do it
is to establish a an entanglement
between where you start some entangled
particles shared between where you start
where you want the information to go
and then you send some classical
information also and you can
use that uh set of information to
basically move the quantum state from
where it starts
to where you want it to end okay and you
can't duplicate it this is this is you
know
a corollary of this thing that when you
look at a quantum system you collapse
its wave function
you can't make another copy of it
there's a literally a theorem the
quantum no cloning theorem you cannot
clone quantum information
but the clever thing that quantum
teleportation lets you do is move
quantum information okay you can if you
have some
superposition of a particle right here i
can turn that into
a superposition of a different particle
very far away
without knowing what the superposition
is without ruining it by measuring it
that's quantum teleportation
ricardo rossera says at the end of a
recent veritasium video derek proposes
poses a question relating general
relativity with accelerating charges
the question is does a freely falling
particle emit radiation because it is
accelerated in the coordinate frame of
someone else at rest on earth
or does a stationary charge emit
radiation because it is being
accelerated by the ground i.e is not in
a geodesic
yeah this is a classic it's a really old
question people fought over for years
and it's the only reason it even seems
hard
is because people are a little sloppy
about what they mean by the word
radiation okay if i have a charge an
electric charge that is just sitting
there
not moving and has not been moving
forever
and i ignore gravity i ignored the earth
ignore general relativity okay just have
a single charge
there's an inverse square law electric
field around that charge
okay an electron let's say and if i take
that charge and now i move it
so i shake it up and down so i need to
accelerate it to shake it up and down
then far away there'll be a little
wiggle in the electromagnetic field that
that arrives at the speed of light right
and
that variation in electromagnetic field
is perceived as radiation
um but really it that makes most sense
like
when you're literally shaking the
electron up and down repeatedly
and making a sort of standing wave that
is that is spreading out in some sort of
continuous fashion
what if i just move the electron a
little bit and didn't move it back
well the the electric field around it
changes
but it's kind of like a wave that goes
up never comes back down it just it was
low
and then it goes up and then it stays up
does that count
as radiation well who cares
is my answer like you know it's a
changing electromagnetic field basically
like what i'm trying to say is
the only reason this is an interesting
question or seems like an interesting
question
is because it asks a question that lives
on the boundary between
static electric field and radiation
where
the definition is fuzzy it's not a
physics question it's just a
definitional question so
if you have a an electron that is
sitting on
my desk here on earth right okay by the
rules of general relativity
it is accelerated right because it's not
on a freely falling trajectory
but who cares what i care about is
is there some time-dependent electric
field far away
that i would detect in a photomultiplier
tube or something like that
if the electron is just sitting there
uh stationary right
then i don't detect anything in a
distant electromagnetic detector so i
would not
call it radiation so this idea
that acceleration and gravity are
similar remember
that's the principle of equivalence
which is only supposed to apply in very
small regions of space time
but the idea of radiation is something
that's supposed to apply in big regions
of space time so it's just
non-overlapping
domains of what you're supposed to be
talking about here
hershey silver says a quantum computer
is exponentially more powerful
because each byte is both simultaneously
one and a zero
however under the many worlds theory the
different worlds once actualized do not
intersect
thus how can a byte in my current
realized world on my actual computer
be quantum put differently once a byte
computes an output
would it not lose its quantum
capabilities for future processing
well i don't know how much you know
about quantum mechanics here but
you've put your finger on what is the
single biggest technological challenge
to quantum computers which is
maintaining the bytes the quantum bytes
or quantum bits the qubits
in superpositions right you are correct
that in order to do a truly quantum
calculation
you need to manipulate and entangle
qubits
without measuring them right so you're
using words like
actualized and realized which are not
words that we traditionally use in
quantum mechanics we use words like
measure
or collapse the wave function or
decohere even better right
once you measure or decohere a quantum
byte then it's not being classified it's
not being quantum anymore sorry it's
classical it's up or down
so you want while you're doing the
calculation
to keep things in superpositions that in
other words to keep them coherent
not let them decohere but once you
measure it
that's how you get the output and indeed
it's true that once you let the quantum
computer do
its algorithm then you measure
the state of your qubits and that
destroys all the quantum entanglement so
you need to start again if you want to
run it again you can't just you know run
it backwards through the quantum
computer anymore you get
an output and in fact you might want to
check that you do it more than once
because you're only going to get the
right at
output with a certain probability at the
end of the management process
james kittik says okay since our mental
energy is near the vacuum state
i agree with you there james here's an
about you question
what what are your eating habits like
are you a three square meals a day
person a grazer midnight snacker
has covered 19 affected this um
i'm a you know two square meals a day
person mostly with lots of cups of
coffee not lots of cups of coffee
three cups of coffee a day it's not
really too much but i generally don't
eat breakfast
uh i'll have a decent lunch a decent
dinner and
um i you know i am someone
you know different people respond
differently to um
times of stress or anxiety and i don't
want to overblown my own
situation because i don't have it nearly
as bad as many people do but you know
this our pre-election state
pandemic state various state of the
world states that we're in
does cause one some worry and and that
affects one's
eating habits as you imply i'm someone
who
comfort eats so i you know if i'm
you know worried or whatever i will just
eat and eat and eat
there's other people who like shut down
and don't eat
uh when they're in anxious situations so
um my uh the thing i need
to control in situations like this is
that i don't eat too much
um you know happily i can't go out to
restaurants with nearly the convenience
anymore
that i could unhappily people will
deliver
food to me like ice cream jenny's ice
cream
is very convenient pizza very very
convenient
wonderful thai restaurants we have here
in uh la
so yeah so i need to you know be careful
not to eat too much let's put it that
way
michael cronin says congratulations
you've been gifted 500 schmeckles
and a star sprinter 6000. what celestial
object do you explore first and why
um so i'm you know i've not read the
catalog for the star sprinter 6000
i'm hoping that it goes faster than the
speed of light so i can go wherever i
want
um it's that's a close one
you know there's sort of three obvious
choices one obvious choice would be
somewhere right here in the solar system
where we think it's
it's um plausible that life might be
like europa or or enceladus like we
talked about
um but if i had such wonderful
technology maybe i want to go further
away
i mean it might be more compelling or
more interesting to go to
an extra solar planet on which
intelligent life might exist
but the problem there is that i think
it's very plausible that the chances
that any one such planet
has intelligent life are very small so i
might just waste the trip
so part of me says that the real fun
thing to do would be to go visit a black
hole
you know get up close to it without
falling in and i think that you know the
one black hole that we know about
with highest confidence is the center of
our galaxy sagittarius a star
so that's probably where i would go i
would just check it out and if you want
to know you know other than
getting to tell my friends i visited a
black hole what would the scientific
payoff of that be
i think you could um measure the
curvature of space-time around the black
hole and see if it
lined up with our expectation from
general relativity that's an important
science experiment to do
peter bamber says as an object
approaches the event horizon of a black
hole an observer at a safe distance
sees the object become ever slower and
never sees the object cross the horizon
but that observer sees black holes grow
how can that be when the observer never
sees anything actually across the event
horizon
uh this is a good question but there is
an answer to it you know
um and i have to blame myself and other
scientists for just
being sloppy when we explain these
things like i already alluded to this in
an earlier question but there is a
calculation
that says imagine you have a test
particle okay so a test particle is
something that is
moves slower than the speed of light so
and technically it has a mass
but it has zero gravitational field okay
so a test particle is the limit
of a massive particle as you take the
mass to zero
okay so it's not a real physical thing
that we can actually imagine but we can
ask about what the test particle would
do in general relativity and the answer
is it follows what we call a geodesic
right a path that is curved but it's
trying its best to move on a straight
line
and then you can make a statement that a
test particle falling into a black hole
would never leave the past light cone of
an observer at infinity that's what it
means to say an observer would never see
anything across the event horizon okay
but in the real world in the real world
you don't have test particles you have
real particles that really have mass
and that means they really have a
gravitational field and that means
that as that particle approaches the
black hole
not only is the black hole pulling it in
but the particle itself
is exerting a gravitational pull it's
deforming the space time around it
so it happens and people have gone
through this and checked it
essentially what happens is because of
the gravitational field of the infalling
observer
which is usually neglected but you
shouldn't the event horizon of the black
hole
expands it reaches out to cover the
in-falling observer and swallow it up in
a finite time not in an infinite time
so that's how you see black holes grow
because you need to take into account
the gravitational field of what's
falling into them as well
peter humble says have you ever seen the
science fiction series called devs
what did you think i did see it in fact
there's an
i think an interview with me again my
memory is not that good and it's not
getting better over time let's put it
that way
i think it's not an article i wrote i
think it's an interview with me in the
new york times
about devs about my uh opinions of the
quantum mechanics in devs and look
it was it was a fun series it was
perfectly worth watching as
fiction it is not in any sense
accurate physics okay it's not it's not
trying
i shouldn't say it's not trying maybe it
was trying you should certainly not
judge it by how accurate its physics is
how about that
says i'm troubled by the prospect of
infinite many worlds do you decrease
your credence towards infinite many
worlds because of the quantitative
qualitative difference between the
infinite and the finite um
no i don't you know we have an argument
i was a co-author on a paper
saying that the hilbert space of quantum
gravity is locally finite dimensional
not infinite dimensional
but our argument there is based on
physics it's based on
jacob beckenstein's argument that there
is a max amount of entropy
you could never fit into a region of
space
i had no conceptual problems with
infinity
i know that there could be conceptual
problems with infinity once you
especially once you have uncountably
large sets there become questions that
are very difficult to answer and puzzles
and things that seem paradoxical
i'm not sure whether they should be
paradoxical or not i honestly don't know
i appreciate the point of view that says
that well
those puzzles would go away if you just
stuck to finite
things but on the other hand i think
once you learn
that in the conventional way of thinking
about infinity the number of
points on the real line between 0 and 1
is equal to the number of points in the
real line between minus infinity and
infinity
right the the infinity from the real
line comes from the smoothness of the
real line it doesn't come from the fact
that it's infinitely big
once you learn that in my view not in
everyone else's but in my view
that reconciles you to infinity a little
bit infinity
is just a way of talking about
continuity and smoothness
not about things that are so far away
that i can't see them
so i have no trouble um imagining that
there could be infinitely
many worlds or the universe isn't really
big or anything like that
i try to be humble about questions like
that i'm open-minded
valkia says when trump caught kovad you
and a lot of other people who think he's
an awful person
and president still wished him a swift
recovery
while a lot of others felt like he got
what he deserved and would have enjoyed
a good amount of shot and freud from him
either getting worse or even dying
i struggled a lot with this because it
was by far the biggest challenge to my
personal
philosophy i've encountered yet i don't
think he deserves death
but at the same time he's a deeply awful
person who spent the last four years
making life miserable
for a lot of people and indirectly
killed hundreds of thousands if not
through koba than through enabling
various extremist
behaviors the conclusion i came to after
a week of deliberating was i won't wish
him death but i don't have to wish him
well
even though i think everyone by default
deserves sympathy when bad things happen
to them
i also think people can through their
actions lose that right
so my question is in your personal
philosophy what is the reasoning that
leads you
to actively wish him a swift recovery
despite him not extending that courtesy
to anyone else
um so i'm very sympathetic to the idea
these are tough questions you know i'm
i'm you know very much um as a moral
constructivist it would be hypocritical
of me not to allow people to have
different moral takes on these
um and we can talk about why we come in
different directions so i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna harshly condemn anyone who
disagrees with me about this i'm open to
changing my own mind about it down in
the future
my own view is you know i i think
the idea that um
he deserves bad things to happen to him
is probably not the right way to think
about it not that it's wrong
uh or right it's just that those qual
those those categories don't apply
um i am a big believer
in you know punishment
as something that affects your behavior
right you know whether it's putting
people in jail or finding them or
whatever or other forms of
um negative reinforcement to stop people
from doing bad things
but i'm not a big believer in punishment
because people deserve
it i think that's just sort of a
leftover from
our lesser instincts that we evolved
over evolutionary
time um so i i'm not
moved by the argument that well he's a
bad person he deserves bad things
happening to him um i am moved by
something that hilary bach who's a
philosopher at
johns hopkins said on twitter and i
retweeted um
she she argues that our attitude
towards bad people what they deserve and
what they don't deserve
is not about them and how good or bad
they are
it's about how good or bad we are
i want the world to be better i want the
kinds of behaviors that donald trump has
engaged in that have brought
misery and death to many many people to
stop
but those are not predicated on him
personally suffering
right if i could make them stop
and not make him suffer i would do that
right
unless like i said there were some you
know deterrence
future deterrence kind of thing like i'm
all in favor of
judging presidents after they leave
office
for breaking the law you know i don't
think there should be any immunity for
presidents
uh just because they once were the
president um because we will have future
presidents and we want them we don't
want them to get away with anything just
because they're the president
but i'm i'm not as a general rule
a thorough consequentialist about
morality
i am not someone who thinks that i'm not
a utilitarian i'm not someone who thinks
we can add up
good and bad and we try to maximize the
good and minimize the band i think it's
more complicated than that
i'm not a strict deontologist either i'm
sort of wishy-washy and in between
here is an area where i'm mostly
consequentialist
so my question to myself is would
donald trump suffering and dying from
this disease make the world a better
place
or does it just you know speak to our
worst instincts and i think that mostly
it just speaks to our worst instinct i
want him to lose the election
that's what i want i don't want him to
die it doesn't make the world a better
place for that to happen
dan o'neil says when i think of the
branching there's a little whiplash here
going from these questions this is
this is uh let me let me pause to say
this is probably my favorite ama
because i really love this month that
we're doing we're in the middle of right
now because it's really a diverse
fun brain stretching set of questions so
good on you
patreons out there in the midst of
global disaster you're able to come up
with a lot of fun set of questions
dan o'neill says when i think of the
branching four-dimensional space times
the many worlds interpretation of
quantum mechanics it's very hard for me
not to picture this as a branching that
takes place
in some larger pre-existing space-time
that they would all
inhabit the way the branches of a tree
occupy the block of space that is my
backyard
but i'm pretty sure this larger framing
is not required is there a better way to
picture
many worlds or do i need to accept that
it's unpicturable um
good uh part of me wants to say it's
unpicturable but of course
that depends on how
realistic you want your picture to be
right
you know everyone has seen pictures of
of little like tree diagrams like a line
goes up and then it branches in two and
then each of the two they branch into
two more themselves and many worlds is
kind of like that
i mean that's a way of visualizing
something but you're just visualizing
lines on a piece of paper you're not
visualizing whole
three-dimensional realities ultimately
these theories live and die by their
strict mathematical descriptions and how
those descriptions fit the data
they do not live and die by our ability
to visualize them
so you know what i'd like to say is
space-time
exists within the worlds the worlds do
not exist within
space-time there's zero reason
conceptually or mathematically
to imagine all of the branches living in
some bigger
space but it is very very difficult to
imagine visualizing them
unless you do that's why it's hard to
accurately visualize them when you draw
that little
tree diagram on a piece of paper there's
a piece of paper that is separating the
lines right it's just almost inevitable
so
i i i'm comfortable saying
you shouldn't expect things like this to
be picturable in any standard way
the human brain just wasn't involved to
think about these ideas
clausion rooney says i think it's really
cool that you're now also an external
professor at the santa fe institute my
question is
what in complexity do you hope to find
out given your quantum mechanical
explorations of
hilbert space um you know i there's not
necessarily a direct relationship
between my quantum mechanical
research and my complexity research they
except
for the fact that they both arise from a
certain foundational
cast of mind and here i'm sort of
invoking
terms of art to distinguish foundational
from fundamental
there's something called fundamental
physics which in most people's minds
is roughly speaking field theory and
particles gravity
you know the basic fundamental laws of
physics and there's the foundations of
physics which are a little bit more
philosophical a little bit more
conceptual
and may or may not refer to the
foundational level
so when i work on the arrow of time for
example why does the past seem different
than the future that's absolutely in the
foundations of physics
but whether or not it's fundamental
physics depends on your particular
viewpoint on what the answer might be
the paper i'm trying to get done
now on causation and the arrow of time
has almost nothing to do with
fundamental physics but is absolutely
foundational you know why why do causes
precede effects
how do you get more foundational than
that right so i mean maybe um
the answer is this is this maybe it's
not your question but this is
you know i i answer the questions that
are asked with the answers i want to
give whether or not they match up the
questions
sorry about that um the thing that
connects my quantum mechanical research
with my complexity research is that it's
done by me
and i am interested in these
foundational questions
now there are people who will you know
ask questions about well
why do causes precede effects in quantum
mechanics
right or where is the quantum arrow of
time come from so there's overlap
between these questions and
i may or may not be interested in them
but there's no direct
connection between these different kinds
of things i'm talking about
johnny says if you could install your
consciousness into an
android and effectively extend your life
that way indefinitely
would you do it assume all hurdles have
been overcome in that process and that
you retain all your ability for thought
emotion and feeling
so i'm i'm going to hesitate about this
one because i am
very very unsure that this is possible
um in in the following sense i
am quite high
credence on the idea that we can imagine
building conscious creatures
in androids or in artificial
intelligence or something like that i
see
no fundamental need to have neurons and
wet biology
to make consciousness you can make
consciousness in all sorts of different
ways
but i am a little bit skeptical that it
would be
me that it would be my consciousness
right it would be some
extension of my current self into
something different
and you know i would go back to the
podcast i did
with lori paul about transformational
experiences
transformative sorry transformative
experiences and and laurie's idea is
that
there are situations of rationality
where
the way that you would judge something
good or bad
depends on who you are right and this is
that's an obvious statement like some
people like tomatoes some people don't
like tomatoes right
but there are questions that come up
where
the decision that you have to make
happens when you're one person and the
consequences of those
those decisions are felt when you're
another person that's a transformative
experience
so how do you act rationally in that
situation do you
judge whether you want this to happen or
not by your current
self or by what your future self will be
the standard example is
turn into a vampire most people don't
want to become vampires but once you're
a vampire you like it
but of course you would you're a vampire
so i have no idea
given the current state of the art what
the continuation of me
would be like if that continuation took
the form of an android
so uh plausibly it would be fun and
interesting and
uh worthwhile to imagine extending my
life that way and possibly wouldn't be
again i'm just being honest about what i
don't know
jan smith says will there be a branch of
the wave function which trump is not
re-elected
uh yes if you believe many worlds there
absolutely will be
many branches like that the question is
what is their
weight what is their thickness what is
their amplitude squared what what uh
measure do we put on them in the wave
function of the universe
that requires action on our part to
effect
dan inch says what are your views on
geopolitical
geopolitical tensions with china and
russia
as a physicist you must have had a lot
of contact with your peers in both
countries and have probably visited one
or both a couple of times what is your
perspective
look i mean both china and russia are
also number one obvious caveat
i'm not an expert i'm really just not
sorry but you know like i said before i
had my opinions
um china and russia in their own ways in
very very different ways
are um big important
countries with rich histories and
vibrant cultures
okay the world would be best off
if these two countries as well as others
were stable flourishing democracies
that worked with the rest of the world
to make us all a better place
right now neither china or russia is
anywhere close to a democracy
the chinese economy is doing well the
russian economy is not doing that well
those are things that can change as we
know over time
one worries whether or not there are
implications of the fact
these two giant countries are not
democratic for the stability or
fragility of other democracies that
already exist there's no law of nature
that says that once democracies form
they stay forever in fact if anything
the law of nature is the opposite right
um there are plenty of people here in
the united states
who are envious or admiring of the
chinese system less of the russian
system the russian system is more
gangstery
but the chinese system even though it is
absolutely an autocracy
where plenty of individuals don't have
rights that we would consider to be
important rights
it's efficient in some ways um they can
get things done
right i mean there are people who admire
that and and you know wistfully wonder
what it would be like if we could get
things done like that here in our messy
uh democracy personally i am super duper
dedicated
to the idea of democracy as flawed as it
is as
as obvious as the shortcomings are um
it's way better than any other
possibility and
um my question about china in particular
is
whether or not their system is so
resilient
that democracy will just never catch on
you know china
has never historically been democratic
for any in any
substantial way for any substantial
period of time
and so i mean i don't think it's genetic
or anything like that but there is
culture there is history there is
you know education um and it might just
be
that people don't have the
sort of cultural memory to say like yes
we should go back to being a democracy
because they never have
and that i think is a terrible tragedy
given all the people
who live in china you know i have
visited china i've never visited russia
i had a wonderful time visiting china i
mean it's
such an amazing place i've had chinese
graduate students plenty of them
actually
um you know lots of brilliant physicists
come from china there's no doubt about
that brilliant thinkers in other ways
um but it's a big complicated country
you know it's it's the biggest most
complicated country
on earth and uh you know who am i to
make any judgments about it let's let's
just say that
robert callahan says how would you now
answer question number two
of lecture 23 of your dark side of the
universe great courses book
and that 2007 book you anticipated the
observational of grav
the observation of gravitational waves
now in 2020 what further do you
anticipate
in the dark side um i'm
you know i haven't looked at the book i
don't know exactly what i said uh
it was in 2007 it was a safe bet
that we would someday find gravitational
waves and we would someday find the
higgs boson
right it might have been hard to predict
exactly when but you know within a
reasonable period of time was a sensible
thing to bet
i think it's safe to say
that now there are no
sure things like that it's never a super
duper short thing but there's
nothing where you would say oh yeah 99
chance there's this hugely important
thing that we haven't found yet but we
will find it
right you could say that in 2007 but it
was the two examples were the higgs and
gravitational waves
we found both of those the next
obvious thing the most important most
likely thing to happen is we would
directly detect the dark matter
but like i said the chances of the ways
that we have of doing that
haven't yet paid off and so the chances
that we will do it on a short period of
time or maybe
less rosy than they were a little time
ago still could happen any day
right you don't know um but it's up in
the air and there's no guarantee it's
absolutely possible that whatever the
dark matter is it's not something we can
detect with human technology so
so i don't know we could find the other
thing that we're looking for
cosmologically is um evidence of
inflation in some way
in particular gravitational waves from
the early universe um we thought
briefly that we had seen those remember
bicep two they went away
some people make mistakes that always
happens it's okay um
but there that's i mean that's not
that's just an idea that may or may not
be right it's not like dark matter that
we have evidence for
uh so we'll we'll look but we don't know
that's all i can say sorry
spencer hargis says in the many worlds
interpretation how do computers behave
let's assume my computer is not hooked
up to peripherals or the internet can i
assume that a process running on the
computer will do exactly the same thing
in almost all the branches of reality
that result
um yes in almost all but not in all
uh that's exactly what you can assume
yeah you know the right way to think
about it is there's no difference
between practical predictions of the
probability of observing one thing or
another
in many worlds versus any other
interpretation of quantum mechanics
um not exactly true sorry there are
other interpretations where there's
extra
weird things but the standard textbook
interpretation of quantum mechanics
gives you the same predictions as many
worlds does for
the kinds of experiments that standard
textbook quantum mechanics is good for
so it has nothing to do with many worlds
what are what is that
you could rephrase your question as what
is the chance
given the rules of quantum mechanics
that if i run my computer in a room all
by itself it will get the right answer
and the chance hopefully is very good
unless your computer is broken for some
reason and
that's not my fault can't help you there
anders
says i guess you don't write papers with
this in mind but which one of your
papers is most likely to win you a nobel
prize
uh yes it is uh true that i do not write
papers with that
in mind uh for a couple reasons one is
it's just not a healthy attitude to have
you know trying to win the nobel prize
um but another is there are certain
kinds of papers
for which you could win a nobel prize
like the easiest way sorry not the
easiest there's no easy ways
um the way that most people win nobel
prizes
is to find something experimentally
right to detect gravitational waves or
to find the higgs boson or whatever
although the higgs boson people didn't
win the nobel prize because the
team was too large maybe they will win
it hopefully they will win it soon the
theorists want it
for theorists who might want to win the
nobel prize
the kinds of theory that will win it for
you are
generally writing down what we call a
model
so what i mean by this is um theorists
can do different things sometimes
theorists will try to
uh you know explicate the general
structure of some kind of theory right
um other times theorists will try to
come up with
a specific theory and it's that latter
kind of thing which we call model
building
which is much more readily
nobel prize worthy right if you build a
model and your model turns out to be the
right model
like when stephen weinberg wrote down
the electro week theory in 1967 you're
gonna win the nobel prize
everyone agrees on that okay that's just
easy you got a little piece of reality
you got it right um the conceptual stuff
it's harder you know and i say this
knowing that roger penrose just won the
nobel prize for a very conceptual thing
you know
he didn't invent general relativity he
showed that general relativity
uh there were singularity theorems which
if you believe in cosmic censorship
imply the existence of black holes
i would not have bet i was surprised
that he won the nobel prize i think it's
very
worthy of it clearly especially now that
we have so much empirical evidence for
black holes
but it's not generally the kind of thing
that nobels are given for
and it is the kind of thing that i like
to write papers about right so my
favorite papers are not model building
but sort of understanding the conceptual
bases of things that's not the nobel's
uh um stock and trade as it were
having said that i've i've written
models down you know it's good it's a
good healthy thing to do
um i wrote down a theory of dark energy
uh you want to write down a model that
makes very specific experimental
predictions
um i wrote down a model of dark energy
that makes very specific experimental
predictions
uh for what is called cosmic
birefringence
rotating the plane of polarization of
photons they travel through the universe
and um probably
that is my most likely nobel prize
winning
um paper because it's i wrote the paper
you know single author i'm not sharing
with 3 000 other people i made a very
specific prediction
now it's not a hard prediction like you
don't need to be genius
to write that paper that i wrote but you
know if it turns out to be true then you
can get lucky
and i say this you know um knowing that
last week uh someone wrote a paper
claiming to have detected
cosmic by refrigerants not well not to
have detected but to to get
very faint but plausible evidence for
some by refrigerant so if that i might
talk about that more in an upcoming
podcast
but um if that holds up
then that would be incredibly
wonderfully important
uh would teach us a lot about dark
energy most likely
and uh might even be the kind of thing
that would increase my chances of
winning a nobel prize
from 10 to the minus six to ten to the
minus four
something like that uh or even more but
you know that but not very much in in
any event
the other thing that i did that you know
is plausible i mean i wrote papers on
the rents violation
if there was a lorentz violating vector
field i i could possibly win it
i wrote papers on modifying gravity to
explain the acceleration of the universe
but there are other people also wrote
kind of similar papers so it's harder to
say
so you know i'm not if you're if you're
on predicted or
ladbrokes or whatever betting site you
like to hang out at i would not put a
lot of money on me winning a nobel prize
anytime soon
joseph tongreti says quantum
entanglement is usually
described so sorry let me just the
finishing thought on that is
even if my paper with chips evens on
deriving the born rule in the many
worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics
is 100 correct and revolutionizes the
field
of foundations of quantum mechanics zero
chance i'm going to win the nobel prize
for that right that's what i mean by
this conceptual stuff
not being uh what the nobel prize
committee is very interested in so
the kind of work that i care about the
most and i'm most proud of
is the kind that is least likely to win
the nobel prize there you go
okay joseph dungaretti says quantum
entanglement is usually described as
happening between pairs of particles
like spin up and spin down are there any
circumstances where entanglement can
occur among three or more particles all
becoming entangled together
um yeah absolutely 100 in fact if you if
you um
either read my uh part in something
deeply hidden where i talk about
immersion space time
or uh if you go to back back to my
solo podcast on emergent space time and
gravity coming out of quantum mechanics
the whole scheme relies on the fact that
there can be entanglement between an
infinite number of degrees of freedom
scattered across the universe
so yes there very easily can be and also
three not just infinity
three particles can be entangled there's
if you look up ghz
state okay you'll see various thought
experiments you can do with
three entangled spins eric coker says
you asked jeremy england this week on
how his work could be applied to our
understanding of the anthropic principle
and the fine tuning of the universe
i want to let you answer your own
question does studying non-equilibrium
cystic mechanics and its relationship to
life
change your feeling about the anthropic
principle and fine-tuning so
it could change it i mean it wouldn't
sorry it wouldn't change my feeling
about it
it might change the specific numerical
credence that i would attach to the idea
that we live in a multiverse versus we
just live in a one-shot universe
because that argument uh
cares a lot about the likelihood the
probability that life arises
in a random universe right how finely
tuned do the laws of physics
need to be to allow for the existence of
life
if really really really finely tuned
then that increases the probability
there's a multiverse and we're just
seeing the part where life can exist
if life existing is pretty robust
then you don't need them you get less
benefit from imagining that there is a
multiverse it's important to
to remind people that the multiverse was
not invented to solve fine-tuning
problems
it was invented because i mean i don't
know who invented it but it was not
first pursued by working cosmologists
in order to solve fine-tuning problems
it was pursued because theories
predicted it
right the string theory landscape and
inflationary cosmology
it was instantly realized that it might
be relevant for
fine-tuning problems in fact you know
other people had mentioned that before
but it was never popular among
cosmologists until the idea was
became predicted by responsible theories
brent meeker says there is an idea that
the universe started very small but at
the maximum possible entropy for its
size
the started small but maximum entropy
story implies that the number of
available microstates
increased with expansion which would be
irreversible and non-unitary
my question is why should we in the
absence of a quantum theory of gravity
assume that the expansion of space
cannot increase the microscopic degrees
of freedom and allow the first story to
be true
um you know you can assume whatever you
want again free country it's always a
matter of what
uh scheme seems more plausible to you so
for those of you who are not quite
following this question it makes perfect
sense
um if you think about the world as a box
of gas
right do you think if you forget gravity
okay um
a bunch of photons or something like
that and imagine the world you know the
universe
is a sphere so imagine it's a closed
universe just to make our lives easier
so it's finite in size
then when that sphere is small there's
only a certain number of things that the
photons inside can do and when it's
bigger there are more things that they
can do and
the maximum entropy changes depending on
the size of the universe
um so that's what brent is referring to
maybe
when you know someone like me says the
early universe was low entropy
maybe that's true but what we really
should say is it's high
as high entropy as it could have been
given that it was small
now my view is that that's completely
nonsense
for a whole bunch of reasons one it
treats the size of the universe as an
external parameter in general relativity
that's not true the size of the universe
is
part of the phase space it's part of the
set of degrees of freedom we use to
describe the physical system
you're not allowed to say if the
universe is small what is its maximum
entropy because the physical system
that is that universe didn't have to be
small
right it could have been big so the
maximum entropy is when it's big
you're not allowed to sort of
pre-existingly externally make it be
small
the other thing is if you imagine the
thought experiment having the universe
collapse
okay and it's exactly if you believe in
reversible laws of physics
then the set of things that can happen
as the universe expands is the same
set as what can happen as the universe
collapses just run backward in time
and our universe i even wrote a paper
about this um
there's a i wrote a couple papers but
there's one called um how finely tuned
is the early universe or is the universe
um if the universe collapses it does not
smooth itself out
it gets lumpier as it collapses you make
black holes you make regions of empty
space the whole bit
and so you just would never get to this
small
region of universe where everything is
smooth because most states don't look
like that right
so brent is correct in saying well
if we give up on the assumption of
reversibility
then that would change the story right
if somehow the laws of physics were
irreversible if somehow
there was some fundamental time keeping
in the universe that had the property
that at what counted as early times
the space of possible configurations of
the universe was just
smaller than the space of possible
configurations at late times then that
would explain the arrow of time
so sure that would explain it but
it is entirely
incompatible with everything we know
about the fundamental laws of physics
so you can you should pick your poison
here right i mean
yes you can imagine throwing out
everything we know about the fundamental
laws of physics
and inventing a solution to the aero
time problem the basis of that
but good luck you know coming up with a
complete and rigorous and sensibly
defined
alternative to the current laws of
physics that's harder than it sounds
so my favorite strategy moving forward
is to stick with the
general form of the laws of physics as
we know them not the specific laws but
the general form of those laws and try
to explain the arrow time within
that and within that within our current
framework for understanding the laws of
physics
the early universe has nowhere near as
high of entropy as it could have had
gary miller says do physicists know for
sure that infinity exists in the real
world
uh no physicists don't know anything for
sure literally nothing
no one knows anything for sure you
shouldn't care about knowing things for
sure you should care about
what credence do we have on different
ideas and we don't even know whether
infinity exists in the real world with
very high credence right if we're
honest we say we just don't know that's
that's one of these very very deep
questions where
there's no experiment that we can
currently put our fingers on that really
gives us any information one way or the
other
bill seltzer says you've written that
reality all of it is represented by a
vector in hilbert space
the world is a wave function in
hilbert's face and
the world is a vector in hilbert space i
think these are three different things
that i purportedly
said i take these to be equivalent
before
clinton herbert feigle used to ask what
do you mean by
is is this the is of composition as in a
car is made of parts
the is of identity as in the morning
star is the evening star or the years of
definition
a brother is a male sibling or or
predication
ball is blue or some other is so what
kind of is do i mean when i make these
statements
so when i say the world is a wave
function in hilbert space or the world
is a vector in hilbert space i'm just
being slightly sloppy
what i mean is the first formulation
that you gave
the world is represented by a vector in
hilbert space a vector in hilbert's
space is an abstract mathematical
construction as i've already said
earlier in the ama
the world is the world the world is
reality so what i mean
is representation i forget whether this
is
one of your options i think it's closest
to identity but not exactly
um i'm not saying that the world is
identical to a factor in hillary's space
because vectors in hover space are
abstract and the world is real
and concrete but all of the properties
of the world
map on isomorphically to the properties
of a vector in hilbert's space that is
what i mean
maxim alexandrovich says if we are
inside a black hole
could there still be branching happening
which would result in creating
new two-dimensional layers on the event
horizon as this would be according to
the holographic principle well there
certainly could be branching inside
a black hole no no problem with that
whatsoever uh you say which would result
in creating new two-dimensional layers
in the event horizon i don't think
that's how it would work
um it would result in uh
the i mean sorry let me pause a little
bit here because i guess depends on what
we mean
um you could
define branches in different ways this
is why i'm i'm hesitating so here's an
older question that is much easier to
wrap your head around if someone
measures the spin of a particle 100
megaparsecs away
and they get spin up or spin down do are
there now two
copies of me right away like not a
hundred
million light years years later but like
right away is in some sense did i branch
all over the place
um and this is an interesting question
uh for people who care about many worlds
and the answer is
you can say it either way you can read
david wallace's book
um the immersion multiverse on the
mending world's interpretation
and he talks about different schemes for
how you could implement branching so
a similar thing and the reason why is
because branches are human
contrivances right the reality the
quantum version of the boss's demon
knows the wave function of the universe
it's like the branches are like a coarse
grained emergent property and so there's
different ways to slice them literally
likewise for the black hole so should i
think of myself as branching
when some quantum measurement happens
inside a black hole you know sadly the
answer is
i could if i wanted to but i don't have
to okay there's no
observational uh difference to the
exterior of the black hole the black
hole still seems
to be a featureless thermal membrane as
far as we're concerned
pablo's papa jordu says what shape is
decoherence
does the universe start out as a solid
block of hilbert space and coherence
hollows it out
giving zero amplitude to regions that
are inconsistent and lowering its
fractal dimension
so no um you know
the universe is not a region of
hilbert's space at all it's
one element of hilbert's space there is
a uh there's some subtleties there
uh because if you take two elements of
hilbert's space
that are just one is a numerical
multiple of the other then those count
as the same physical state you can scale
the vector by any number helper space is
a vector space
visualize the two-dimensional vector
space if you multiply a vector by a
number
it extends out in length but goes in the
same direction
so the higher dimensional hilbert space
version of that is the same
you multiply by what matters is the
direction in which the vector the vector
is pointing
but there's no block of hilbert's face
no region of hilbert's face
that is being hollowed out now having
just a vector in a vector space doesn't
seem like nearly enough information to
be the world and
that is an ongoing research program that
my
friends and i are trying very hard to
figure out how do you go from
something as abstract and austere as a
vector to the richness of the world and
the answer is
going to depend on how you choose to
represent that vector
hilbert's space has a little bit of
structure because of the hamiltonian
which drives quantum states to evolve uh
gives it a bit of structure but
telling that story specifically is a
hard and ongoing project that we're
working on
keith asks do you know of any theories
that toy with the idea that dark matter
is residual
heavily decayed gravitational
interaction with wave function branches
i don't know of any theories like that
but you know
there isn't any there shouldn't be any
residual gravitational interaction
between wave function
branches the branches are really
distinct um
you know you can numerically quantify
how distinct they are it might not be
100
but it's 99.99999 etcetera percent
and remember there's more dark matter in
the universe than there is
ordinary matter uh and but but much more
importantly
the dark matter acts just like a
non-interacting non-relativistic
particle
you can make predictions on the basis of
numerical simulations about how
dark matter should cluster in galaxies
and clusters
how it should affect the growth of
structure in the cosmic microwave
background
based on the hypothesis that it's a
particle that doesn't interact with
other particles it just moves slowly
through space
and all those predictions come true so
you can bend over backwards to come up
with a more
elaborate theory of dark matter but it
would be
weird if a very elaborate theory of dark
matter had
all exactly of those properties you know
once you have
some kind of theory in which the dark
matter interacts or
um is either self-interacting or
interacting with ordinary matter
usually those theories are ruled out
very very quickly not always but you
have to work
hard at it steve m says
ask your opinion on the quanta article
about the velocity of
tunneling particles faster than light
nope i have no idea what the article
says so i can't really give you any uh
information there though but i can say
you know as background the whole idea
of particles tunneling faster than light
is
only possible because particles aren't
particles in quantum mechanics they're
wave functions
and how do you define where a wave
is well you can try but there's some
ambiguity there and that ambiguity gives
you
the wiggle room that you can use to say
oh it moved faster than light but
nothing is violating the rules of
relativity i i promise you
then nickel says what are your thoughts
on the axis of evil anomaly do you think
it is a statistical error bias or a real
phenomenon
so the axis of evil is an idea that
there is some structure in the cosmic
microwave background
that picks out a preferred direction
honestly i'm not a super
expert on it so i i i have a small
bayesian prior that something like that
is going to be real just like i have
small basin
priors for any weird cosmological
phenomena
so it's worth studying worth getting
more data on but i don't i haven't heard
a lot of people talking about it lately
i think it's kind of faded away
i worked on similar ideas um myself i
mean maybe this is another
uh is it another way i could win the
nobel prize i did i have a model
with uh lottie ackerman and mark wise
about uh preferred direction
in space but it turned out to make
different predictions than the axis of
evil so that would be
uh something different brad malt says if
you were writing your higgs boson book
today instead of 2012 what would be the
biggest difference
or to put it another way what is the
most exciting development to have come
out of cern that isn't included in your
book
so the sad news brad is that
the biggest difference is that i could
say you know
after we found the higgs boson we kept
looking for other particles and we
haven't found any
that's the big news um i forget i wrote
a blog post once where i made
predictions before the
lhc turned on about what it would see
and you know i had
some hefty probability on finding
nothing
um not greater than 50 though it was
less than 50
i thought we would find something else
besides the higgs boson
but that seems to be what's happened and
you know that is a
kind of clue that guides future
exploration
but it's not the most helpful kind of
clue right and you know okay you found
nothing so
what are you gonna do like believe me if
we found any other particles
or even any other interactions between
existing particles at the lhc
other than the minimal standard model
higgs boson you would know that would be
front page news
bendy bruce says should we build a
bigger hadron collider and
are the reasons why or why not well you
know i think
the basic idea here is extremely simple
if we don't find anything else at the
lhc which the jury is still out
finding new particles is extraordinarily
helpful
in pushing the frontiers of physics
forward so we can understand more and
more things
and you can try to do that by a
cleverness
right you can try to do it in basement
tabletop experiments
or via astrophysical information or
something like that
but there's no guarantees you find
anything and those techniques are way
less powerful
than building a giant collider for
finding new particles
by far the best most productive way to
find new particles or new physical
phenomena is to build a giant collider
that's the one side the other side is it
costs money
that is literally the only reason not to
build a bigger hadron collider is that
it costs money
and that's not a trivial reason it costs
a lot of money right you know it's a
non-trivial
chunk of cash you can you know play the
games where if you imagine
every human being on earth contributing
you know once per day or whatever
it's it's pennies or less that would
require to build this thing but you can
play that game with lots of different
costs
in any realistic accounting it's
expensive to build a bigger hand-drawn
collider i would love to see it built
is it worth the money is something that
individual governments
are going to have to decide well not
individual governments no individual
government
has the capability to do it except maybe
the u.s and we have no interest
so it's going to be an international
collaboration either in china or in
europe
yet another sign the united states has
left behind
the leadership of the world in an
important way
philip meyman says if someone discovers
a new law of nature but dies before
telling anyone
and no one ever learns it no one else
ever learns it and no one's lives are
changed in any way
was that still science or does science
require some communication or impact on
the world
on the one hand sure of course it's
science you discovered something new
about the world
you know after all eventually we'll all
be dead and science will have
nevertheless happened
in our lives while we were going on here
on the other hand
i can't i can't really get that
emotionally invested in questions like
this i mean you're not asking about what
happened you're asking what label we
should put on what happened
and i'm pretty pluralistic about that
but whatever labels on it you want if
you don't want to call that science
knock yourself out chin
says your take on the level of reality
i presume what you mean is how real is
the following quote
in some way or other spacetime itself
seems to fall apart at a black hole
implying that space-time is not the root
level of reality but immersion structure
from something deeper and this is from
a recent quantum magazine article by
george musser about the black hole
information paradox
yeah i'm very sympathetic to exactly
these words exactly this philosophy and
by the way this quantum magazine article
is an explication of some of the stuff
we talked about with neda engelhardt
on the podcast recently magneta's
picture is in the article so you should
check that out
the article is good the headline is way
overblown that's why i didn't retweet it
or anything like that
uh it says basically we're close to
solving the black hole information
paradox and if you remember listening to
neda
she explicitly says we do not know
whether or not this is the right answer
so
i'd be much more cautious than quanto
was in this case
christoph pyronsky says why do we insist
that extra dimensions are small and
curled up inside our 3d space
why is our whole 3d universe not a slice
of some higher dimensional space
which we can't live li sorry which we
can't reach
the same way that flatlanders can't
leave flat land um
it's possible that we do live on a 3d
universe
embedded in a higher dimensional space
the traditional reason
why that would have been hard to imagine
being true
is because even though you can confine
things like the particles and forces of
the standard model
to a three-dimensional sub-manifold
which we call a brain right
b-r-a-n-e from membrane we could be
confined to a
three brain in a higher dimensional
space but there's one thing that is hard
to confine
to a brain which is gravity gravity is
the curvature of space time if you're in
a bigger space time
gravity leaks out into the bigger space
time and if gravity leaks out into the
bigger space time
you don't have an inverse square law for
gravity the inverse square law comes
about because space is three-dimensional
there are extra hidden dimensions of
space
that are big then gravity can leak out
into them
so the ways to get around that are
either to make the extra dimensions
small
so that gravity can't leak out in them
traditional way
or to warp them this is what lisa
randall and robin sundrum became famous
for
the idea of warped extra dimensions they
can literally be
infinitely big but so highly curved that
the gravitational field cannot leak out
into them so that is absolutely
a possibility on the table for how
dimensions work
martin lesser says a well-known
biographer of einstein among others has
stated that to solve problems
involving acceleration one must use
general relativity
the idea that special relativity cannot
deal with acceleration seems to occur
fairly often
what are your feelings about this and
have i missed something in understanding
what these people are talking about so
just to be clear and i think martin and
i are on the same side here
there's zero problem with talking about
acceleration in special relativity
the idea the difference between general
relativity and special relativity has to
do with
the fact that in special relativity
space-time is a
fixed background with zero curvature
which we call minkowski space and
there's no such thing as gravity
in general relativity space-time is
similar to special relativity but it's
dynamical it can be warped and bent
and we experience that warping and
bending as gravity
so you notice that nowhere in those
words i use anything
like acceleration right of course
without gravity i can still accelerate
nothing wrong with being a rocket ship
and accelerating whether or not there's
any gravity around
at all the reason why people sometimes
make the mistake
this mistake is because there's
something you can do
in special relativity that you can't do
in general relativity
precisely because space-time is rigid
and fixed
and in a very special flat way thus the
name special relativity
there's a kind of coordinate system you
can set up in space time
that is adapted to the motion of
unaccelerated observers
what we call inertial observers so if
you're moving in special relativity
unaccelerated you can define a reference
frame and
extend it uniquely throughout the
universe okay
and you can define what you mean by
simultaneity or
distance or time based on those
reference frames
in general relativity even if you're
unaccelerated
you cannot extend
your reference frame uniquely throughout
the whole universe because space time is
curved and it would sort of get in the
way in some in some way
so in some sense the combination of
being
unaccelerated and in special relativity
gives you a special ability to do
something you couldn't otherwise do
but who cares who cares about extending
your reference frame throughout the
universe
just because i can extend my reference
frame uniquely
if i'm not accelerated doesn't mean i
can't imagine being accelerated i mean
my goodness
the twin paradox one of the you know
most popular things you talk about in
special relativity
requires that a twin accelerate off in a
rocket and then accelerate back
it'd be really weird to say you can't
talk about the special the twin paradox
in special relativity
right okay so it's completely uh
misapprehension even if you can try to
invent some reason why they would have
that misapprehension
george robinson says photon pairs can be
created which are entangled
it is also the case that individual
photon wave functions can pass right
through each other without interference
but an individual photon can interfere
with itself question mark
so i don't think you quite nailed having
a question there george even though you
have a question mark
but i think i get where you're at
however let me let me you know back up a
little bit here
um you have to distinguish between the
wave function
of the photon and the classical
electromagnetic field
they're related to each other
conceptually and you know if you sort of
visualize them in your head
they might be similar but they're
different things okay
they're fundamentally different so when
you say words like individual photon
wave functions can pass right through
each other without interference
i suspect that what you mean is the
individual
electromagnetic field pulses that you
might
associate with photons can travel
through each other without interference
of course they don't travel through each
other without interference if you have a
an electromagnetic field that is
vibrating up and down
and you have two wave packets that are
headed toward each other
then they absolutely will either
constructively interfere or
destructively interfere with each other
when they overlap
it is also true that an individual
photons
wave function can interfere with itself
but that's a different kind of thing
so i hope that makes some sense i'm not
quite sure what
if that's addressing your question but i
did my best nicholas vyberg says
i heard about ongoing activities to
measure the impact of gravity on
anti-matter
are there respectable theories in which
antimatter behaves differently compared
to normal matter
perhaps even with a repulsive force how
would that fit with general relativity
where gravity is not a force
but a curvature in space-time so i think
there are theories but they are not
respectable
is the right way to say it i think that
there's basically
zero good reason to think
that matter and antimatter should behave
any differently at all
in a gravitational field you know and we
talked earlier about test particles
small particles whether they're
electrons or positrons or roughly
speaking test particles they move on
geodesics of space-time so
they would behave exactly the same in
the gravitational field of the earth or
the sun for example
you can try very hard to invent theories
that predict something else then you can
go experimentally test them
that's a good idea because if you find
something you'll win the nobel prize
much more likely than i will but the
reason why your overall chances are
still small
is because probably gravity doesn't
behave like that that's why it's hard to
win the nobel prize as a theorist
because
either uh you can do sensible work
within the frameworks we already
understand and that's not the kind of
thing nobel prizes are given for
or you can propose laws beyond what we
understand which is great but they're
probably wrong
because most proposals are going to be
wrong there's many more ways to be wrong
than to be right
that's why physics is exciting but also
kind of hard
steven scully says do you feel classical
mechanics is adequately represented in
academic pursuit of fundamental physics
and if so
why is no representation enough
again i'm not quite sure i parsed the
sentence there but classical mechanics
is
absolutely part of academic physics i
mean we teach it obviously but there are
people who do research on it
usually under the name of nonlinear
dynamics
because linear dynamics is too simple
like you know linear just means if i the
harder i push the faster something moves
right
non-linear dynamics means that the
response that something has when i act
on it
obeys a complicated relationship it's
not a simple input output
proportionality it's something more
elaborate than that and non-linear
dynamics is very important most
real dynamics in the world is non-linear
i think the point is the basic rules of
classical mechanics were
set down by isaac newton and they
haven't changed uh people like hamilton
and lagrange and so forth came up with
alternative formulations of the same
rules and that was good that was fun
those alternative formulations are
useful for various purposes
but the rules haven't changed so it's
not like
particle physics where you could imagine
inventing a new particle and someday
detecting it
there's not a lot of money to be made
inventing new rules for classical
mechanics that that game is kind of over
jarrod driven gerard driven says if
space-time is a lot of fields together
and these same fields are here in us and
around us and even torn apart in geneva
then sometimes i think that the mass of
the earth is nothing else
than rolled up space-time the question
is are there tiny black holes to be
found
in regions close to the smallest scale
near the planck scale
um we think so
so you know one so this is a quantum
gravity question we don't understand
quantum gravity whenever you're
combining gravity in quantum mechanics
you should
tread lightly because we don't know any
answers for sure
so if i can translate your question into
the more traditional language of
particle physics
you know when two electrons interact
with each other in a feynman diagram
kind of description we draw pictures of
the two electrons
passing photons back and forth to each
other we label these as virtual photons
and we say
the reason why the electrons scatter off
of each other is because of the exchange
of virtual photons
so can you say the same thing about
black holes you know since
electrons interact with gravity and
black holes are little bits of gravity
little bits of curve space time
is part of the interaction between two
electrons due to the exchange of virtual
black holes
and the answer is yes we believe the
answer is yes it's a little bit
um speculative but not too much so it's
you know there's there's things that
should happen just on the basis of
the robust features of quantum field
theory the reason why no one cares too
much is because gravity is really really
really really weak
you know if you've ever if you've ever
been an undergraduate physics major and
had to do the cavendish experiment
had to measure the gravitational force
between
two heavy objects but in a lab it's
really really hard because gravity
is weak imagine measuring the
gravitational force between
two electrons that's very very in fact
it's impossible
right we technologically speaking and to
imagine measuring
the part of the gravitational force that
is due to the exchange of virtual black
holes is harder
still um this goes this harkens back a
little bit to the earlier question about
wheeler's geometry dynamics you know is
there space-time foam
at the planck scale does that contribute
to particle physics in some way
these are the kind of words that are fun
to say but don't quite add up to a
sensible theory
in the in the sense of our other
theories of physics right now so it's
fun to think about
but until you turn it into a concrete
mathematical proposal it's really hard
to know what to make of it
yienna ferdivik uh ferdivec sorry i'm
not
sure how to pronounce the name um makes
a suggestion about a future
guest geraldine heng who wrote about
england and the jews
uh again thanks for the suggestion maybe
the amas are not the best place to put
the suggestions
you know honestly you can just go to
patreon and send me a message if you
have a suggestion i get a lot of
suggestions
so please do not feel bad if your
particular suggestion is not taken up on
but i do look into all of them you know
i take them seriously
oria biddle says is creating a black
hole in a lab on earth physically
possible and if so why haven't we done
it yet
well it might be hard to get permits
from the international regulatory
commissions but um
it's possible sure to make a black hole
if you mean you know metaphysically
possible
is it is it conceivable sure um is it
is it technologically practical is there
any way that we know how to do it
no you need an enormous amount of matter
and energy in a
very small region of space to make a
black hole we don't know how to do that
now there was an idea that was very
popular and sort of faded away a little
bit
that the large hadron collider or
another big particle accelerator could
make
black holes and that was based on the
idea
of extra dimensions of space because if
you have
large extra dimensions of space then
gravity can leak out into them
a little bit and what that means is that
gravity is stronger than you think
because the reason why we perceive
gravity is weak in our world according
to these models
is because it's largely leaking out into
the extra dimensions
and only we only feel a little remnant
of it in some sense
and what that means is that if gravity
is much stronger than you think
it's much easier to make black holes
than you think so this was the idea that
maybe you could actually make black
holes of the large hadron collider
but as we said it didn't happen nothing
happened other than the higgs boson
so there's been no evidence so far for
black holes at the lhc
probably those models were just on the
wrong track um
and if those if they are if they're not
right then there's no feasible way that
we can think up to make black holes here
on earth
abdul apsal says i've seen william lane
craig and others
argue that causality can be a temporal
one example they often cite is taken
from kant where they invite you to
imagine a heavy ball
resting on a cushion from eternity past
and causing an indentation of the
cushion prima fashion this makes no
sense to me
as it seems to me to be a snapshot of a
dynamical process in time
where exactly is my reasoning going
wrong
i agree with you that is a bad example
the heavy ball causing an indentation on
the cushion
um but there might be better examples so
it depends on what you mean by causality
okay i mean causality is an ancient
concept
aristotle talked about it 2500 years ago
and
aristotle didn't know about modern
physics he didn't know about laplace's
demon or quantum field theory or any of
those
things so it should be the least
surprising thing in the world to imagine
that
our modern view of causality needs to be
a little bit
different than our conventional
intuitive natural language
view of causality so there's a view of
causality which is
fundamentally temporal right causes
precede effects we hear
but there's other notions of causality
so for example
you can ask why is electric charge
conserved
and someone could say well because of
gauge invariance because of a symmetry
of the underlying equations of
electromagnetism
so in some perfectly reasonable sense
someone can say electric charge is
conserved because of gauge invariance in
the underlying equations
that would be a good example of an
atemporal cause
it's not that gauge invariance happens
and then
electric charge is conserved they both
happen simultaneously
but more important you have to recognize
that this notion of the word cause
is just one of the various notions so
you have to be very careful
to specify what you mean when you say x
causes y
sam hart hartsog says could you
elaborate a little on the concept of
scale invariance and what if any
relation it has to inflationary
cosmology
um yeah sure you know i talked about
scale and variance again in one of the
biggest ideas
videos i had a video on criticality and
complexity
and criticality in this sense is very
closely related to the concept of scale
invariance it means
something is happening on all scales
right so
rather than so the example that is often
used is the height
of let's say you know adult american
women
okay not all adult american women are
the same height
but there is a common height there's
sort of a traditional height there's an
average height that is well defined you
know the
women are not scale invariant nor are
men or any other organisms
um so it's you're it's very unlikely to
find
one foot tall adult american women and
it's very unlikely to find
20 foot tall adult american women
somewhere in between is is where they
lie
whereas scale and variant phenomena you
can find something going on
at every possible scale and there are
examples of that
in nature the the uh application to
cosmology
is that when we look at large scale
structure in the universe
either directly in galaxies or in
were basically the same amplitude
at every length scale so the
variations on large scales that
stretched over what are now megaparsecs
and the variations on small scales that
stretched over what are now
meters or kilometers or of the same
rough size
that seems to be an experimentally
observationally empirically true
fact about the universe inflation can
explain that
inflationary cosmology when thought of
as a theory of the origin of density
perturbations
generically robustly predicts
approximately scale-free perturbations
because the rate of inflation is
approximately constant
so inflation is continually creating new
fluctuations and they get stretched by
the expansion of the universe
so inflation creates fluctuations at all
length scales of approximately but not
exactly the same
size and that is size in the sense of
amplitude not a linear size
and that's more or less what we see so
to that extent inflation is a very
nice way of explaining the
scale-free behavior that we see in
cosmological perturbations
john eastman says are atoms shrinking
rather than space expanding why is this
the question
why is this the uh the big question
today i don't really know
um see earlier comments you can think of
it that way but i wouldn't recommend it
see my answers get shorter every time i
answer the same question
mark moore says is it reasonable to ask
what the pulse width of a photon
is um no not really there's really no
such um
well-defined thing you know um
it's tricky once you get into it because
photons are intrinsically quantum
mechanical objects
right so you should first you know get
familiar with the classical theory of
the electromagnetic field and so you can
say okay
if you've ever taken electromagnetism if
you've taken a class in it would you
realize that the first thing that they
tell you about when you study waves or
radiation
are what are called plane waves that is
to say
like a sine wave or a cosine wave that
literally stretches
forever it has no edges right it just
goes on throughout the whole universe
we all know that's unrealistic but it's
very easy to solve the equations
in that case and there's no size of it
it has a wavelength
it has oscillates up and down but it
stretches throughout the universe
and then you learn a little bit about
fourier transforms and other
mathematical techniques and you learn
that
you can take those kinds of plane waves
with different frequencies different
wavelengths every individual plane wave
stretches forever
throughout the universe but a specific
combination of plane waves can describe
a localized wave
packet we already mentioned wave packets
when we talk about the speed of quantum
tunneling
so you can get a classical
electromagnetic field
that is sort of more or less zero
outside a certain region
and inside a certain region it's
oscillating and that little pulse
oscillation
moves at the speed of light but that's
all classical talk
right we haven't talked yet about
quantum mechanics and i'm not going to
go into the whole thing
um but each individual plane wave
is what we first we we we play the same
game over again in quantum mechanics
that i just mentioned in classical
mechanics
every plane wave is the thing that can
quantum mechanically describe
zero particles zero photons one photon
two photons etc
and then you can superimpose you can
combine
the one photon state corresponding to
many different
wavelengths to make a one photon state
that is a localized wave packet
but you can do that with any width you
want as long as it's compatible with you
know being
at least as long as the wavelength
itself of
the electromagnetic waves
so james o'sullivan says veritasium just
made a video about how it's impossible
to measure the one-way speed of light
which blew my mind
do you have any ideas about what this
might mean in terms of new theories of
gravity um
so i did not see the video so i can't
comment on that and i'm not exactly sure
what the argument is that he has in mind
i'm sure it's respectable um and i'm
pretty sure it has
zero meaning for new theories of gravity
you know measuring the speed of light
is a question whether or not you know
the extent to which you can do it and
what it means to do it
is formulated purely within the context
of special relativity where there's no
gravity at all so
whatever your difficulties are measuring
the speed of light it has zero impact
on gravity which is another kind of
thing
patrick hall says what is your opinion
on the reality of ordinary macroscopic
objects
are they real or are they simply
illusions of our object discriminatory
faculties or neither of those um
yeah i think they're real i'm sitting on
a chair i think it's real i do not think
the chair i'm sitting on is an illusion
of my discriminatory faculties you know
you can
talk yourself into thinking that the
chair is an illusion
but why would you do that what do you
gain by doing that
you know i think that it's a weird
definition of illusion
that you would have to believe in to
think of the chair i'm sitting on
is an illusion it's not fundamental
chairs are nowhere to be found in the
standard model of particle physics it's
a macroscopic emergent feature of the
world
but it is part of what daniel dennett
calls real patterns
go back to the podcast i did with dan um
the the idea the concept of a chair
is very useful when you discuss the
world
right you know if you think about the
world as a giant vector in hilbert space
or even just classically as a collection
of a whole bunch of particles
there's an in in literally infinite
number of ways you could imagine
carving up that world into parts
and then describing how the parts
interact with each other almost all of
those ways are going to be useless
but some ways of carving the world up
into parts are really really useful
when someone points over to one side of
the room and says could you bring that
chair over
you know what that means right
information has successfully been
conveyed to you
that's not what an illusion is like an
illusion is like you know you see an
oasis in the desert
uh but it's really just vibrations from
the heat
that are fooling you into thinking that
there's water there that
illusion has no causal efficacy you can
say oh i'm thirsty i will walk over to
the oasis but there's nothing there
you're not going to get any water
right when you have concepts that really
do have useful causal efficacy in the
world
i think that we should just call those
real okay last question we've reached
the end
uh robert grenise says can you explain
the page
curve named after dawn page and what it
tells us about the information escaping
a black hole
so this is also something a concept
that's mentioned um
i think that neda englehardt mentioned
it and it's certainly mentioned in the
quantum article that we referred to
that is very recent the page curve is
just this when you make a black hole and
you let it evaporate like stephen
hawking says you might imagine doing
you want to know is it possible
that the information gets out that the
information that went into the black
hole
is contained in the radiation that is
leaving it right
and if it is what would that allow you
to say
about the radiation because hawking's
calculation
what what hawking did in the 1970s
gives you no way for the information to
get out it you know it makes a
prediction
based on some assumptions and we think
those assumptions can't be right
but but under hawking's assumptions the
radiation that comes out is exactly the
same for every black hole
regardless what kind of information went
into making it
so dawn page asked well what if the
information somehow does get out
and what if which many of us think but
is not exactly completely
proven you know what if the
entropy that we're talking about here is
the entanglement entry the quantum
mechanical entanglement entropy okay
so as soon as you make the black hole
information starts coming out or sorry
um photons start coming out right
radiation starts coming out and even if
that um well it's not even if
if the information is going to get out
then those photons have to be entangled
with what's going on inside the black
hole otherwise they can't carry out
information
okay the quantum information is largely
contained in the entanglement
so what that means is that the photons
coming out have entropy
entropy is one way quantum mechanical
entropy is called
sometimes entanglement entropy it's a
way of quantifying the degree of
entanglement so
as more and more radiation comes out the
entropy of that whole set of radiation
goes up
it increases with time until you hit a
point where roughly speaking
the number of degrees of freedom inside
the black hole
becomes equal to or less than the number
of degrees of freedom
in the radiation that's already escaped
and in that case
it is the black hole that is the smaller
subsystem and the radiation that is the
bigger subsystem
and there's sort of less room for there
to be entanglement because the black
hole is shrinking and shrinking and
shrinking there's less
stuff for the radiation to be entangled
with
so the page curve is just the curve the
plot the
graphical representation of the entropy
entanglement entropy of the radiation
escaping a black hole and it's the
simplest curve in the world it goes up
and then it hits a peak and then it goes
down that's the page curve
and the point the reason why it's
relevant is because it's a nice little
quantitative thing that it doesn't
follow from an elaborate calculation it
follows from the robust basic features
that you want
information to get out and it's it's one
of the things that is a target for you
if you're inventing a new theory of
quantum gravity or a new way of thinking
about quantum gravity
you want to be able to predict the page
curve so when page predicted it he
didn't have a theory that predicted it
he just said
this had better be the case if
information gets out
so a sort of standard um
test that you want to put your idea
through if you have an idea about how
the information gets out
is that it better reproduce the page
curve
now i'm not sure if that made sense that
explanation but i think what i said is
true it's also explained in the quanta
article so you can check it out there
and i think that is the end of the
questions at least i mean this is a long
thing probably more questions have
appeared as i'm doing it but i'm gonna
i'm gonna call it uh victorious for the
day um
happy election week everybody happy uh
quarantine happy whatever we're going
through in the world
hang in there we'll all make it it'll
all be okay
i promise okay bye
[Music]
you